[Zene]
köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót a
következő vendégem lukácsi kata ügyvédnő
egy számomra nagyon kedves ember akit
pár évvel ezelőtt ismertem meg és azt
hiszem az legjobban úgy tudnám bemutatni
hogyha egy történetet mesélek erről sőt
kettőt is el tudok mesélni ami ami
bemutatja a a a az izgalmas karakterét
katának az első az most történt nemrég
amikor a rájöttem hogy a cégünk nagyon
sok adót fizet túl sok ad ót fizet és
megkerestelek téged hogy nem-e lehetne
valahogy optimizálni ezt a szót is tőled
tanultam hogy nem adóelkerülés hanem
adóoptim
optimalizálás és emlékszem hogy elmentél
a polchoz levettél egy könyvet ami agyon
volt olvasva tehát látszott rajta hogy
szamárfülek mindenhol meg látszott hogy
nagyon-nagyon sokat forgattad egyből
odan nyitottad ki ahhoz a paragrafushoz
ami pont arról szólt és magamban
elkönyveltem hogy nem csak hogy tehát jó
helyen vagyok ha ha adót akarok
optimizálni akkor jó helyen vagyok
úgyhogy ez egy ez egy ez egy nagyon
kiváló példája annak hogy egy jó üvédnek
látlak és egy emellett egy nagyon színes
karaktered van mert nem csak
hogy hogy ügyvédként már 19 éve mindjárt
20 éve az úyvédi kamera tagja vagy tehát
hogy ennek a szakmának a mélyén vagy
hanem emellett egy két gyerekes
családanya is vagy és emellett a köz
közös ügyekért rengeteget teszel ez a
másik történetem is hogy
a cégünk létre akart hozni egy oktatási
központot és persze zöld fülüként hogy
azt se tudtam hogy egyesületet vagy
pedig milyen jogi formát akarok
létrehozni és amikor az első kérdésem az
volt hogy hogy hogy kihez forduljak
mindenki a te nevedet mondta úgyhogy
elmentem hozzád és emlékszem hogy egy
hihetetlen órát beszélgettünk tehát én
én utána is teljesen fel voltam kavarva
a beszélgetés után egyrészt azért mert
láttam hogy nagyon foglalkoztat téged
egyből a mélyre láttál hogy ez az ignis
mint oktatási központ amit amit
létrehoztunk hogy ez ennek ennek
mélysége van hogy ez többről szól az
hogy a jogi alapjait nem értem az
egyáltalán nem jelenti azt hogy nincs
ennek egy értéke és a másik amit mondtál
az hogy minden egyes évbe kinézel
két-három projektet amit szeretnél
támogatni ahogy minket is támogattál
nagyon kedvezményes áron végezted el ezt
a munkát és ez a az oldalad ez is egy
izgalmas oldal amiről majd szeretnék
beszélgetni a közösségi oldal és
és igen szóval kedves hallgatók
figyelmébe ajánlom hogy lukácsikata egy
jó ügyvéd akit amit magáról nem mondana
el soha így hogy ő egy jó ügyvéd de én
el tudom mondani több ügyben tanácsot
adott már nekem és egy nagyon izgalmas
beszélgető partner úgyhogy köszöntelek
téged kata szervusz köszöntöm én is a a
nézőket hallgatókat azért az első
történethez egy annyit hozzátennék hogy
hozzátartozik az igazsághoz hogy én
azért sosem gondolnám meg más szakember
sem gondolná azt hogy én adójogi
szakértő vagyok így a a szó legszigorúbb
értelmében pont az a téma amivel te
felkerestél azt tudtam de azért sem
könyvelő nem vagyok sem könyvvizsgáló
úgyhogy nyilván bizonyos részletekre van
van rálátásom és esetleg tudásom de
azért nem szeretném hogy többet
képzeljenek bele ebbe az egészben mint
ami én vagyok hát attól függetlenül ez
volt az volt a tapasztalatom egy tehát
az az hogy az a k könyv rongyosra volt
olvasva az mindent elmond nem és és
amúgy zárójelben megjegyzem nem csak ez
a könyv van a polcodon és sok könyv
rongyosra van olvasva í hogy láttam így
távolról hát én ilyen öreg vagyok hogy
én még mindig ugyan számítógépen tehát
törvénytárból dolgozok de mégis én
szeretem összefirkálni vizuális
típusként sokkal jobban megmarad ez
nekem úgyhogy én én mér még mindig
szeretem a papírformátumot arra lehet
hogy már nem emlékszel de az is biztos
hogy azt a könyvet le is ellenőriztem
hogy ma ez van-e éényben igen emlékszem
emlékszem a laptop ült és egy pár perc
után igen egyből meg is mutattad át is
küldted át is olvastuk és azóta is
nagyon hálás vagyok mert egy rengeteg
már azóta ez az adóoptimalizálás már el
is indult a cégünkön belül úgyhogy
úgyhogy tényleg ez egy ez egy ez egy
nagyon nagyon szép példája volt annak
hogy hogy tényleg egy egy egy jó
szakembernek látlak
igen szóval van egy csomó kérdésem
nagyon-nagyon sok kérdésem van a
szakmáddal kapcsolatban de nem akarok
egyből beleugrani inkább az első k
kérdésem az lenne hogy miért
választottad ezt az ügyvédi szakmát
mikor döntötted el hogy te ügyvéd
szeretnél lenni az igazsághoz hozz
tartozik hogy én már ötödik osztályban
egy egy felmérésen ezt leírtam ezt a
pályát volt egy ilyen felmérésünk és a
én már akkor leírtam hogy én majd
filológiaosztályba fogok menni
gimnáziumba utána báberzsolyai tudomány
egyetem mert hogy én ügyvédt szeretnék
lenni persze más egy ötödikes fejjel ezt
gondolni és más akkor amikor tényleg ott
áll az ember nyolc osztályban vagy 12
osztályban hogy tényleg ez-e az útja de
továbbra is ez maradt az utom ha tőlem
megkérdeznéd azt hogy milyen meséket
szerettem akkor én ha olvasnak nekem
vagy ha ha én olvasok akkor én én mátyás
király meséket szerettem csoda-e hát
hogy ezt a pályát választottam tehát
hogy engem ez érdekel ez vonz az
igazságosság ez nem jelenti azt hogy
mindig igazság van vagy mindig győz az
igazság de nyilván ezt én még akkor nem
tudhattam aztán megtanulja az ember hogy
a az igazságszolgáltatás és a
jogszolgáltatás az nem ugyanaz és hogy
romániában jogszolgáltatás van nem
igazságszolgáltatás de erre később
jöttem rá mindenképp ez egy ez egy löket
voltm a másik pedig az hogy azért volt
jogász a a családban édesanyám akkor
lett ügyvéd amikor én kilencedikes
lettem addig jogtanácsos volt úgyhogy
volt egy példa láttam az árnyoldalakat
is és nem tudtam magamnak mást
elképzelni tehát bármilyen pályában
gondolkoztam
nekem ez volt a legvonzóbb meg az amit
úgy éreztem hogy én én fogom tudni
szeretni ezt csinálni a ami izgalmas
volt nekem az az uf
rendezvény nem az az uf rendezvénye volt
igen az uf rendezvénye volt amikor a
nőnapi alkalmakkor ugyancsak erről
beszéltél és engem nagyon megérintett
azóta is emlékszek rá hogy azt mondtad
hogy annyira nem ment jól azért az
egyetem mint ahogy í és rengeteg
alázatot érzek ebbe meg nyilván
gondolhatná valaki ebből azt hogy ha nem
megy jól akkor lehet hogy pályá
tévesztett most már utólag tudjuk hogy
nem tévesztettél pályát de volt-e benned
ilyen gondolat hogy hogy amiatt nem megy
esetleg a legjobban mert mert pályát
tévesztettél nem it kellett volna legé g
vy másnak sem ment jól nem voltak akik
nagyon ügyesek voltak
gyakorlatilag én abban bíztam hogy nekem
nem két lábon járó törvénykönyvnek kell
lenni és nem is vagyok az üüm én abban
bíztam hogy ide egyéb képességek
kvalitások kellenek illetve az hogy én
szeressem ezt csinálni én ezért tudok
lelkesedni én tud m hogy én tud segíteni
h ha majd ott leszek van nekem egy
logikus gondolkodásom nagyonnagyon
fontos ugyan lehet hogy furcsa lesz amit
mondok de a matematika legalább az
eg8olc osztályos matematika egy logikus
gondolkodás kifejlesztéssíven segít és
nekem nagyon jó matematika tanárom volt
az egy teljesen más dolog hogy én utána
a filológiát választottam mert hogy az
is érdekelt de nyilván a a szövegek
értelmezésed szétszedése ugyanúgy kell
tehát hogy én ezekben jó voltam nekem
ment a matematika tehát nem azért
választottam a ol ológiát mertogy
mertogy nekem nem ment a matek én azt
szerettem a fizika nem ment egyáltalán
sőt tehát hogy teljesen nulla vagyok
fizikából és de a logika az igen kellett
meg a szövegértelmezés olvasni szerettem
nagyon-nagyon jó magyar tanáraim voltak
nagyon szerencsés vagyok óriási nagy
dolog ma is hálás vagyok
nekik viszont az amit kértek tőlünk a
felvételére románia történelme 11-es
12-es anyag szóról szóra ez nekem nem
ment a román nyelvtan az nagyon ment
tehát ugye abban van logika szuper
tanárnőm volt a kaláio tanárnő és és
nagyon ment mikor mentem fel felvételi
előtt tesztelni az eg az egyetemen
dolgozott az illető tanárnő akihez
jártam teljesen meg vololt lepődve hogy
iln kilences felett írok tehát hogy csak
az elején volt ezen meglepődve és nem
tudok olyan jól beszélni tehát az egy
teljesen másátészta hogy az ember
beszéljen is de nyelvtanból amikor tehát
az egy nagyon-nagyon magas szintű
nyelvtan volt aminek mai nap a a hasznát
veszem az nagyon ment nekem nagyon
élveztem nagyon szerettem csinálni ehhez
képest a történelem a románia történelme
egy götrelem volt én tudtam azt hogy az
egyetemen is ezt kell csinálni hát nem
azt mondom hogy szóról szóra de nagy
mennyiségű anyagot be kell venni úgy
hogy nem tudod hogy azt hogy tehát nem
érted az alkalmazását és most már utólag
érted utólag természetesen viszont én
azért voltam gyengébb az egyetemen mert
én nem vagyok képes semmit megtanulni
míg én azt meg nem értem míg én azt nem
látom hogy hy a gyakorlatban hogy
működik ezért aztán én jól elpiszmogtam
mindig az elején és nem jutottam el soha
a végére volt egy olyan rendszer több
tanárnál hogy három tételt adtak hogy
írjál róla körülbelül az elejéből a
végéből és a közepéből az anyagnak és a
kaptam a végéből engem elvágtak tehát
mindenből meg kellett írni az ötöst de
én amit még el se olvastam igen amit én
el se olvastam abból én nem kaptam meg
az ötöst tehát mehettem újra vizsgázni
ez az igazság viszont azt amit
megtanultam az nagyon alapos volt ami ma
is megtart na de most mit mondjak
2011-től arra megváltozott alapjaiban a
polgárjogi törvénykönyv büntető
törvénykönyv a perrentartások úgyhogy
végül is ezért is nem jó az hogy két
lábon járó törvénykönyvek legyünk mert
állandó változás van nekünk jól fel kell
tudni tenni a kérdést jól meg kell
keresni tehát hogy a problémát hogy a
problémakészség kell a problémam megoldó
készség kell erős legyen üüm és az
valahogy ment diák
szervezkedtem ezzel együtt azért mindig
aggódtam megm izgultam meg szorongtam
nem volt egyszerű a nyilvános beszéd
vagy a a megnyilvánulás azért úgy
publikum előtte gondoltam hogy azt majd
gyakorlattal üüm kezelem a helyzetet és
gondolom hogy ez ebben fejlődtél nem a a
hát ha tudnád hogy milyen szinten voltam
mindenképp ez nem jelenti azt hogy
befejeztem tehát hogy mindig van hova
fejlődni mindig
az hogy hogy fejezzem ki magam hogy
őzgetek vagy nem őzgetek hogy a
megfelelő szó éppen akkor a számra jön-e
vagy sem tehát azért gondolom hogy
ismerős az az érzés mindenkinek úgy
utólag hogy há ezt jobban is el tudtam
volna mondani na hát nekem is van ilyen
persze amúgy te egy introvertált vagy
egy extrovertált személynek tartod magad
ez változó attól függ miről van szó a
téma a környezet hol pihensz meg a
csendben pihensz meg vagy az
bár az emberek között is tehát engem
feltöltenek a baráti kapcsolatok vagy én
én bulizni is tudok és jól esik mikor
minek van a helye mikor mi esik jólüm
változó üüm az egyik téma emlékszem
beszéltünk telefonon és említett tehát
hogy az napra nagyon sok per
tehát hogy tárgyalásod nem nem tárgyalás
hanem igen tárgyalásod van
vagy hat hét és akkor jöttem rá hogy
volt egy ilyen gyermeki kép bennem a
filmek alakították ki hogy egy ügyvéd
hetekig vagy hónapokig dolgozik egy
ügyön és ilyen nagyon kalandos az élete
és mindenféle bizonyítékok utolsó
pillanatban előkerülnek és akkor a az
esküd szék majd a végén dönt és akkor
tehát hogy ilyen teatrális képeket
plantált el bennem a a a
hollywoodi filmek zöme és akkor jöttem
rá hogy valójában lehet hogy nem is így
működik a egy hétköznapi ügyvédnek az
élete tehát az hogy hat hét ügyet
ügyekkel foglalkozzál egy nap
ez ez egyből azt a kérdést hozta fel
bennem hogy lehet hogy egy kicsit kéne
beszéltesselek erről hogy hogyan is néz
ki egy napod neked mint üvéd hüüm hát
azért nem minden napos a hat- hét
tárgyalás szerintem akkor akkor éppen
úgy jött ki tehát változó miközben
hallgattallak épp azon gondolkoztam hogy
ma mondjuk volt egy a tegnap négy tehát
hogy ez ez így változó és nincs minden
nap tárgyalási nap de én tárgyalásnak
hívom sokszor azt is hát van bírósági
meg nem bírósági tárgyalás is hogy néz
ki egy nap pont azért mert vannak ezek a
tárgyalások vagy az emberekkel dolgozunk
és az időt nem mindig mi nem tudjuk
uralni az időt mertogy ugyanúgy várunk
sorunkra mi is a bíróságon míg míg az
ügyeink sorra kerülnek ugye van egy
lista van sorszám és ahogy sorra
kerülünk vagy ahogy nem és ezmiatt
ezeket ezekkel az időkkel szinte nem is
rendelkezem és
ezmiatt kell idő amikor én írni is tudok
meg beszélni is tudok néha rá
csodálkoznak az emberek hogy hát de
nekem miért kell elvonulni írni hát
mondom nem olyan mint a filmekbenagy
csak veszem a lapot és akkor én azt már
fenn tartom és mindent is tudok hát fel
kell készülni úgyhogy én a reggeli
órákban találtam meg azt a csendet ami
amikor engem senki nem zavar amikor fog
az agyam és és akkor dolgozom ez azt
jelenti hogy 4 óra és 5t óra között
kelek egy kicsit ugy el vagyok ébredezek
kávézok és mondjuk fél hétig el amikor
költöm a fiaimat addigra én már nagyon
sok mindent tudom hogy mit akarok a
napomon felkészülök megírok bármi és ez
igazából ad egy olyan lendületet az
egész napomnak mert én aznap már
letettem valamit az aztal amire az fiaim
iskolába mennek én már én már valamit
csináltam f:é0-kor ugye ezt megszakítom
felköltöm őket reggelit kapnak már
mondjuk olyan 7: 10 perckó már nincsenek
is otthonüm úgyhogy én onnan már megint
nyerek egy kis időt amíg még még mindig
hamar visszaülök és írok vagy akkor
akkor kezdek elell készülődni hogy hogy
mit veszek fel az nap vagy egyáltalán
hogy elkészüljek és sokszor azért van
hogy a saját irodámból reggel képes
vagyok elkésni mert amit reggel
nekifogok és megírtam még tudom hogy
csak öt perc hogy be is fejezzem utána
fél óra hogy elürül vegyem az egészet a
gondolatmenetemet igen ez a kontextusált
igen akor igen és akkor hát még azt be
kell fejezni és akkor elkések a saját
irodám volt szóval ez ez szörnyű de még
mindig inkább bevállalom mert nincs időm
hogy annyiszor újraveegyem ugyanazt
tehát hogy ez még kell dolgozzak
párhuzamosan hány ilyen ügyfeled van
ahol nyitott ügyek vannak amivel kell
foglalkoz sok van ezt nem lehet
összeszámolni tehát min napi 10-15 féle
valamivel biztos hogy foglalkozunk tehát
eléggé igénybe veszi az agyat az az
igazság tehát azért az ügyvédeket is a a
kiégés veszélye rendesen fenyegeti nem
tehát hogy mondjam volt egy egy idősebb
kolléga a barátnőmnek a mestere aki azt
mondta hogy ez a szakma nem beteg
embernek való tehát hogy itt itt ben
nagyon ott kell lenni nagyon tehát
hogyha mentális egészséged nincsen akkor
az úgy nagyon-nagyon kemény és igenis
kell azért tenni hogy korban tartsd
magad ühüm sokféle van tehát hogy azért
van itt rutin is tehát van ami
nagyon-nagyon rutinos és van ahol
stratégiában gondolkozol ahol ahol
értelmezned kell nekem például elég sok
olyan helyzetem van amikor nincs rá
törvénykezés nincsen rendelkezés abban
kell kitaláld ügyesen okosan hogy hogy
mégis hogy lavírozol hogy azért a bírót
meggyőzz arról hogy hogy ez igenis
működőképes akkor is hogyha nincs egy
jogszabály ami azt mondja hogy ezt itt
úgy írja ahogy én mondom mert sokszor
egyszerűen nincsen például végrehajtás
témában van három ilyen vastag könyvem
ami a végrehajtásról elvileg mindent ír
és van két esetem amire nem ad választ
hü tehát hogy hogy azért vannak ilyen
nehéz es esetek és tudjuk azt hogy a
bírónak az elsődleges feladata az hogy a
törvényt alkalmazza na most már ha nincs
törvény jogszabály akkor tudsz nyerni
vagy nem tudsz nyerni ühüm ide már kell
a bíró
személyisége aki azt mondja hogy ettől
függetlenül megértettem bölcs vagyok
megértettem hogy mi a problémát és nem
mond ellen semminek az amit te kérsz
ugyan nem is írja sehol hogy ezt így
kell csinálni de átengedem másik bíró
pedig azt mondja hogy nem nem hát nem
írja sehol elutasítalak úgyhogy ez ilyen
nagyon-nagyon változó és hát azért nem
izgalommentes hát itt egyből már egy jó
pár kérdés felmerült bennem mégpedig az
egyik az hogy arról a szintről ahol a
hétköznapi ember nézi a jogot
kicsit úgy tűnik minthogyha lennének
igazságtalan döntések és
lennének igazságos döntések de nyilván
ez a ez az alap tehát elvárnánk hogy egy
bíró igazságosan döntsön és itt
két-három mítosz is így megfogalmazódott
bennünk de sorra veszem és lássam hogy
ezekkel a míoszokkal mit tudunk kezdeni
kezdjük az elsővel az az hogy egy
bíró személyiségén múlik az hogy egy ügy
milyen irányba lesz el elbírálva nem
csak de nem csak de számít nyilván hát ő
hozza a döntést abszolút számít persze
azér mi is ott vagyunk szeretem aztni
hogy én is ott vagyok igen az mi a
különbség az igazságos ítélet és a jog
jogosítél vagy jogszerű ítélet között
mondad hogy ezeg hogyyigad van igen
lehet hogy igazad van csak például nem
tudod bizonyítani na most ha nem tudod
bizonyítani nem fognak neked igazságot
szolgáltatni
ühüm ez ilyen egyszerű és vannak olyan
esetek amikor tehát hogy a mindenrő nem
tudunk bizonyítékot hozni és lehet hogy
erről is majd egy kicsit kell beszéljünk
egy-egy helyzetben a jó ízlésen múlik
hogy például egy hangot hangfelvételt
nem csinálsz vagy vagy min bizonyíték
ami ami ami szolgálhatna hogy hogy
emberileg nem akarod olyan helyzetbe
hozni a másik személyt hogy hogy nem
tudom milyen bizonyítékokat gyűjtesz
róla de viszont abszolút igazságtalan
lenne abb a helyzetben tipikusan
ilyenkor egy például egy nárcisztikus
személlyel hogy egy nárcisztikus személy
végtelenféleképpen manipulálja a
környezetét és és és szenvedést okoz egy
jóízlésű személy aki még ráadásul fel
sincs készülve arra h létezik nárcizmus
az nem fog bizonyítékokat gyűjteni na
most hogyha ilyenkor egy perre kerül a
sor ami gyakran megtörténik mert
ilyenkor egy nárcisztikus személy
probléma nélkül megy és pereli a másik
személyt mit tehet ilyenkor a a az a aki
nem gyűjtött bizonyítékokat nem is csak
az van hogy nem gyűjtött tehát sokszor
nincs is én például most te amí
beszéltél nekem kifejezetten a családon
belüli erőszak jutott az eszembe
nagyon-nagyon nehéz hát hogy van az úgy
hogy igenis például egy távoltartási
parancsot elutasítanak egy ilyen
kérelmet nem bocsájtanak ki mert te nem
tudtad bizonyítani mert ugye ez egy zárt
közegben történik kettőtök között nincs
nyoma igen hiába na itt van
jogszabályunk a jogszabály azt mondja
hogy szóban tetben gazdaságilag satöbbi
tehát hogy ez mind-mind bántalmazásnak
számít de hogy nem tudod bizonyítani nem
tudod bizonyítani míg az a játék folyik
hogy akkor most kiteszek-e az asztalra
100 lejt vagy sem hogy menjél és vegyél
élelmet a családnak és és ez csak egy
apró banális dolog tehát ott van sír az
ügyfeled látod rajta hogy nincs miért
hazudjon nincs de nem tudsz neki
segíteni attól függetlenül azt mondod
hogy hát végülis akár megpróbálhatjuk
nézzük meg de nem biztos hogy nyersz üüm
mertogy a másik esetleg hoz egy tanut
aki azt mondja hogy hát ez egy annyira
jó ember ühüm hogy hát nézzük meg itt és
ott is jótékony bármit és te nem tudod
bizonyítani az állításodat hogy veled
mit követel a lelkileg pedig az is egy
bánalmazás érzemileg hogy tudod viselni
amikor látsz egy olyan esetet amikor
egyértelmű hogy a bíró nem a helyes
tehát hogy amit emberileg megítélnénk mi
nem azt a döntést hozza mert nem tudjuk
bizonyítani akár igen igen ez megvisel
mindannyiunkat tehát tény hogy azért
ugye én elsősorban észből kell dolgozzak
nem engem az ügyfeleim nem azzal bíznak
meg hogy együtt érezzek velük hanem
azért hogy találjak nekik megoldást ugye
ahova már az szemet kell használni
persze ettől függetlenül együtt érez az
ember de együtt tud érezni vele a
barátja is tehát nincs rám szükség csak
azért hogy együtt érezzek vele nem
tudjuk magunkat annyira kivonni viszont
én azt gondolom hogy egy szakszerűséghez
hozzatartozik az is hogy mi ezt
magunkban lekezeljük tehát az
ügyfelemnek az a jó ha én meg tudom
őrizni az objektivitásomat ha én
objektív maradok akkor tudok figyelni
dolgokra amire ő nem na most ez sokszor
nem mer sor tényleg van az hogy elvisz a
történetével ilyenkor már ugy ennyi év
után az ember tudja hogy hátra kell
lépjen egy csöppet és és kell
gondolkozzon kell kell hagyjon magának
időt hogy hogy ez leülepedjen tehát hogy
az érzelmek egy picit alábbhadjanak é
akkor az ész is megjelenik na most
a mit akartam hogy itt a kérdeznék még
egyet ami ennek a fiegészítője hogy ha
ha neked szakmai szempontból objektívnek
kell maradj egy bírónak kell-e
objektívnek maradjon tehát amik tehát
ott van a törvény de lehet kétféleképpen
értelmezni tehát van egy játéka ennek
egy emberi játéka itt jön be szerintem
lehet hogy az értelmezés még mindig
objektivitás tehát minden objektív az én
megközelítésemben ami észből történik a
szubjektivizmus az érzelmek
megjelenésével jelenik meg én én ezt így
tudnám nagyon-nagyon egyszerűen
lefordítani magam dez hogy töféleképpen
értelmezhetünk valamit nem az alapján
fogjuk valamilyenféleképpen értelmezni
mert a világképünk ezt tartja helyes
esnek tehát hogy a bírónak a világképe
hát őket kell megkérdezni de tehát
nyilván hogy befolyásolja őket viszont
én azt hiszem hogy nem feltétlenül a
szövegértelmezésben bár igaz hogy nálunk
a szövegértelmezés hát még a mit én a
jászvárosi iskola és a a kolozsvári
iskola vagy akár a bukaresti iskola
értelmezése se mindig egyezik tehát hogy
hogy ham ennél sokkal nagyobb szinten is
értelmezhetőek sajnos a szövegeink vz
viszont
egy bírónak is azért objektívnek kell
maradni tehát én bízom benne hogyha
esetleg elkapná őt is a a hév a hatása
alá tud kerülni egy-egy ilyen ügynek
márpedig ő is csak egy ember tehát nincs
hogy ne kerüljön hatása alá amikor dönt
már pedig ez nem akkor melegében
történik meg akkor mégis csak mivel hogy
profi
a bizonyítékok illetve a jogszabály
alapján dönt természetesen emberek
vagyunk történik ez meg másképp is
esetleg nem azt mondom de tehát minden
benne van a a pakliban na most amit
mondani akartam az az ezzel
kapcsolatosan hogy mennyire hat ránk
vagy mennyire nem hat ránk nekünk a
fókuszt nem szabad elfelejteni tehát én
ugyan meghallgatom de nem szabad
elvigyen a saját ügyfelem sokszor nem
tehát látom hogy nem esik jól de igenis
meg kell állítsam a történetében mert
nem fontos dolgokat mond az ügy
szempontjából tehtlykor mindent kiönt
amit csak tud így van én nem vagyok
pszichológus és az olyan apró részletek
hogy ú mit tudom én hogy ívott-e előtte
egy pohárvizet vagy sem engem tény
tényleg nem érdekelnek és nem is kell
érdekeljenek az ilyen apró részletek az
én figyelmemet elterelik onnan ahol
fontos hogy ott legyen a figyelmem tehát
közben kell őket egy picit terelni hogy
konkrétan megértem hogy ezt állítja mi
volt mivel tudja alátámasztani milyen
bizonyítéka van satöbbi satöbbi tehát
nekem állandóan vissza kell őt téríteni
és nem szabad elfelejteni hogy
nagyon-nagyon lesz egyszerűsítve nekünk
a bíróságon az eszközeink a jogszabályok
és a bizonyítékok hiába van jogszabály
hogyha nem tudom bizonyítani azt hogy az
az eset az a bizm esetre ráhúzható az a
jogszabály és hiába vannak bizonyítékaim
hogyha nincsen róla róla rendelkezés
mert hogy ilyen is van hát ennek a
kérdésnek a másik oldala viszont az hogy
mi van akkor hogyha egy olyan valaki jön
akiről rájössz útközben hogy hogy nincs
igaza vagy akár még gonoszság is van
mögötte valami szándék valami
manipulatív szán ilyen ilyen volt-e
ehhez volt ilyen igen és akkor ilyenkor
mit tudsz tenni
nyilván az első beszélgetéskor azért az
igen az embernek van egy y
emberismeretel lát dolgokat
csak akkor ilyenkor visszautasítod én
nem kell hát van amikor van amikor maga
az ügyfél hazudik de elsősorban még
magának is például egy bűncselekményel
követésekor amikor bagaterizálja a
tettét mert hát végül is nem történt
semmi például csak ittasan vezettem vagy
csak odasóztam kettőt vagy csak belestem
tehát hogy hogy vannak helyzetek ahogy
terik az idő egyre inkább ez szerintem a
pszichológusok jobban tudnának erre
válaszolni megjelenik ennek a lélektanáb
van az hogy egyre amilyen nagyon meg
vagyok ijedve az elején úgy aztán majd
egyre inkább úgy érzem hogy hát olyan
nagy dolog nem történt most mi ez a nagy
hercehurca van ilyen is van ez az oldala
is nyilván
egy ügyvéd mindig csak abból dolgozik
amit a mármint információból a amit az
ügyfele elmond neki na most ő amit nekem
elmond én ezt el kell fogadjam nem é
akkor elmegyek egy rendőrségi
kihallgatásra ahol szegeznek olyan
kérdéseket az ügyfelemnek hogy hogy
látom hogy hoppá tehát hogy ő nekem nem
mondott igazat nyilván ilyenkor ülsz és
hallgatsz mert nem beszélhetsz az
ügyfeled ellen viszont tény hogy azért
minden egyes első beszélgetéskor én ezt
elmondom hogy én abból dolgozok amit ő
hoz ha nekem hazudik saját magának kárt
mert én arra építek fel én én abba
indítom el a a gondolkodásomat amit ő
mond valaki ezt vagy felfogja vagy nem
viszont én vissza tudok térni ühüm hogy
ugye emlékszik rá hogy én ezt elmondtam
ühüm ugye emlékszik rá hogy ezzel
csökkenti az esélyünket ha már így van
hogy ezt ennyire rá tudják bizonyítani
hogm bejön és azt mondja hogy ártatlan ő
semmit nem csinált volt olyan ügyfelem
amelyik azt mondta hogy ártatlan
viszont viszont mikor arról volt szó
hogy akkor jó egy hazugságvizsgáló
eljárásnak alávetie magát azt mondta
hogy nem és onnantól fogva minden
egyértelművé vált ha elindultál egy
üggyel akkor útközben is visszaléphetsz
én visszaléphetek hogyha úgy érzem hogy
az az
én erkölcsé így van igen igen igen igen
és visszon persze volt rá példa így van
így van volt rá példa másrészt viszont
nem kell szeress az ügyfeleket tehát én
meg tudom érteni a problémáját persze
van aki a szívéhez nő az embernek főleg
az amelyikkel már nagyon hosszú távon
dolgozik együtt most épp büntető példák
jöttek elő de én nem vagyok azért egy
büntetőjogász tehát hogy én nekem kevés
és a könnyebb büntető tehát hogy mondjam
azért ha úgy van én én tudok kollégát
aki jó büntetőjogász és ahhoz küldöm
amikor látom hogy ez egy olyan szint ami
engem meghalad és nem szeretném
elvállalni mert más jobban tudja
csinálni de
hogy attól függetlenül hogy ne nekem már
nem lesz szimpatikus vagy azt látom hogy
hazudott ha én látom azt hogy tudok
valamiben neki segíteni akkor nincs okom
elutasítani tehát ez olyan hogy a boltba
csak azt szolgálod ki aki aki neeked
szimpatikus vagy sem tehát hogyha én meg
tudom találni a abban az ügyben azt
amiben én tényleg tudok neki segíteni és
ezzel benne maradok az én
morális világomban akkor akkor én azt
miért ne vállaljam el hivatalból
kineveznek ügyekben tudjuk hogy lopott
tudjuk hogy megerőszakolta ühüm de jár a
védelem neki és te tudod védeni azt a
személyt muszáj védjem mert hogyha
vállaltam hivatalbeli ügyeket akkor nem
mondhatom azt hogy bocs de ez nekem nem
tetszik akkor nekem jogomban áll nem
vállalni hivatalbeli ügyeketüm de én ha
nem vállalok hivatalbeli ügyeket akkor
én kiesek a gyakorlatból ühüm tehát ez
igazából engem gyakorlatban tart ühüm
nem nem nem egyéb ühü itt itt még tovább
lovagolhatnák ezen a kérdésen de
szerintem menjünk a következő mítos ami
megfogalmazódott így a fejem még mindig
az első mítosznál tartunk a háromból
igen a következő mítosz ami így a
hétköznapi polgárnak a fejébe megfordul
mint nekem az az hogy akinek pénze van
az nyer a a tehát hogy hogy ha minél
több pénzed van annál több ügyvédet
fogadhatsz meg és és annál nagyobb
valószínűséggel fogsz a végén nyerni ez
ez tényleg így van az
igazságszolgáltatásban van egy ilyen
faktor ez szerintem hülyeség úgy ahogy
van abszolút tehát hogy én én ezzel azt
nem mondom több szem többet lát esetleg
ki lehet kérdezni több ügyvédnek a
véleményét de van egy bizalom hol van a
bizalom tehát én megbízok benned hogy te
nekem elmondod hogyha ez a téma téged
meghalad esetleg én mint ügyvéd ha
valamiben bizonytalan vagyok mert
sokszor tehát egy egy csomót mi kell
gondolkozunk egy csomó kérdés felmerül
egy csomó valószínűség számításunk van
mert ha ez így alakul úgy alakul tehát
mi ki kell elemezzük a helyzetet és
megnézni hogy az az út amin elindulunk
az hova vezet nekem mindig kell levegjen
egy cél annak az útnak a végén és lehet
hogy hogy esetleg valami nagyon rossz is
tud történni be tudom vállalni vagy sem
tehát soha nem fehérfekete üüm a a
kérdés éppen ezért
tehát ez bizalom kérdése én megmondom ha
engem valami meghalad nyilván vagy
megmondja a más kolléga vagy nem mondja
meg de az hogy többen vagyunk vagy
többet fizet ez attól még ugyanaz a
tudásom és ugyanaz a helyzetem tehát
hogy ha neki valaki tud engem ajánlani
hogy figyelj ez jó munkát végzett én
megm bízok benne rendben van én nem
látom tehát több ügyvéd mivel tud többet
tehát hogy hogy is mondjam többet tudunk
gondolkozni együtt vagy de az hogy most
hárman álljanak a tárgyalóteremben vagy
hárommal beszélj el is vészik vész a az
információ de valahol ez ez mintogyha
most az amerikai politikát vagy a
külföldi politikát nézzük hogy ezek a
hatalmas büntetőtrgyalások trumpal
például most hogy hogy az az érzésünk
hogy hogy mivel nagyon sok pénze van
ezért mintolódnak az ügyek még mind
valahol meg fogja úszni amúgy nem akarok
én most politikába belemenni inkább csak
ez a megint csak nyugatról jön ez a
tévképzetem nekem hogy hogy egy
milliárdossal szembe hogyha most együk
fel el elkezd perelni valamilyen oknál
fogva valamilyen szándéktól vezérelve
akkor én csak veszíthetek h nem ezzel én
nem értek hegyet tehát egyrészt nem
folytam belele nem követem én a trump
pereit
viszont azt gondolom hogy azok
nagyon-nagyon összetettek lehetnek na
ott indokolt hogy annak az egy ügynek
azt a sok-sok összetevőjét egy-egy
csapatra bízod vagy egy-egy ügyvédre
mertogy
merthogy ott esetleg a a komplexitása
nem aét hanem a komplexitása az ügynek
meg az hogy hogy mjam időben másképp
működnek mindennapos tárgyalás tehát
hogy hogy az tényleg más hogy
gyakorlatilag nem csinálnak mást mint
leosztják a feladatokat igen és nyilván
ehhez pénz kell tehát hogyha te több
embert foglalkoztatsz akkor több pénz
kell de ez nem garancia arra hogy
nyersz neked hogyha ha van
jogszabályalapod és van bizonyítékod ak
akkor az elv az hogy nyerned kellene de
soha nem ilyen fehérek és feketék az
esetek üüm illetve például a
válóperekben ki nyer ühüm a vége nem
ugyanaz hogy elválasztanak házasságban
senkit nem tartanak az akarata ellenérem
tehát akkor miért cirkuszolunk jaj hogy
kinél lesznek a gyerekek tehát hogy
érted ezek ez hogy nyerek vagy
veszitteek ez nem ennyire egyértelmű
ühüm és semmiképp tehát a mi világunk az
nem az amerikai jogrend mi nálunk ez
egyáltalán nem így működik meg is hökken
mindenki amikor először lép
tárgyalóterembe hogy nálunk ez
nagyon-nagyon másképp működik nálunk
például a retorikának nincs akkora nagy
szerepe nem igen kapok én lehetőséget
arra hogy egy nagy persze perbzédet
mondok de például egy
tanúkiihallgatásnál nem az van hogy én
direkt be a tanúval tudok beszélni és
meghallgatom hanem tiszteletteljesen
megkérem a bírót hogy lesz olyan kedves
feltenni a tanúnak ezt és ezt a kérdést
addig a tanú hallja nem felteszem a
kérdést a tanú hüm a bíró azt vagy tehát
én nekem ugye van a fejemben egy
stratégia hogy milyen sorrendben hogy
teszem fel a kérdéseket a bírónak nem
ugyanaz van a fejében nyilván mint nekem
ő a maga során átfogalmazza lerövidíti
teljesen mindegy de már ugyanúgy nem
tudja feltenni a kérdést a tanúnak van
ideje gondolkozni tehát mindenképp az én
kezemből ki van véve annak a lehetősége
hogy ilyen gyorsan hassak a tanura üümm
már csak ez is ez például én
nagyon-nagyon sajnálom ha még fordítani
is kell mert ugye nekünk ez a a
sajátosságunk hogy nem mindig értenek
románul vagy aki ért románul se mer
beszélni mert tudja hogy annyira nem ért
románul és minden szó számít akkor még
ugye még a fordítással is teljesen
elvész akár a szöveg na ez bosszantó
egyébkén bosszantó tehát jobb lenne
hogyha direkt beszélhetnél vele és ak az
any nyelvedel igen igen és ott meg
tudnám fogni igen jó lenne ha még a bíró
is értené hogy hogy fogom meg vagy nem
persze ettől függetlenül azért van van
az úgy hogy tehát hogy nan meg tudom
fogni nem arról van szó hogy nem mindig
vagy de hogy van az a helyzet mikor nem
tudom megfogni mert ha példá dörzsöltebb
hányszor van az hogy mit én rángatják a
talárodat hogy hazudik hát mondom értem
hogy hazudik de mit csináljak vele nem
kaphatom őlbe próbálom megfogni kereszt
kérdésekkel de igen nem mindig sikerül
egy ilyen környezetben sokkal jobban
tudnék rá hatni direktbe én is más is ja
amúgy ez engem nagyon megnyugtat hogy
ezt mondod ez tényleg elhittem hogy a
pénznek van egy ilyen hatalma de hogyha
azt látod hogy ha van is valamennyi nem
domináns ez én nem így élem meg nem ez
ez megnyugtató és akkor idejön a
harmadik mítosz ami a fejemen így felé
épült remélem hogy ezt is le tudod majd
rombolni amikor az adóoptimizálással
kapcsolatban beszélgettem más cégekkel
az első reakció az volt mindenkinek hogy
rendben rendben kaptam egy jogszabályt
de az adó ellenőrzés alatt úgy is meg
fognak büntetni mert mert valamit
kitalálnak hogy nem fogadják el mert
mert mert tehát hogy hogy nem lehet
egyszerűen a a jogot így értelmezni és
az az igazság magamban is elkaptam az én
lelkemben ezt a nyugtalanságot volt
ameddig veled nem találkoztam és kétszer
háromszor rá is nem kérdeztem de mindig
maga nagyon magabiztosan mondtad hogy ez
van leírva fehéren feketén és újra
felolvastad én pedig úgy voltam vele
hogy azáltal hogy felolvasod az annyira
nem nyugtat meg azáltal hogy magabiztos
vagy az igen úgyhogy ezt ezt hogy látod
igen ez egy érdekes kérdés na most azért
mivel te olyan rettenetesen csodálkoztál
azon amit mondtam nál nekem meg mivel
már csinálja más is tát tudom tudom hogy
más is gyakorlatban úgy dolgozik ezért
én nyilván felhívtam azt a könyvelési
szakértőt akiben én megbí á megérem
válzott valami mi hogy még ő is
megerősít tehát hogy azért a magabiztág
az onnan isön hülye nem lehetek tehát
hogy ez egy speciális terület a a jog az
ugye mindent átsző mindenhova
befurakodik értünk a joghoz de mi nem
értünk egy csomó mindenhez nem értek az
autóalkatrészhez amiről én pert
fogalmazok meg mert mondjuk hibás a
motor nem értek egy csomó mindenhez
ugyanígy könyvelő sem vagyok topográfus
szakember sem én ezekkel az emberekkel
szorosan együttműköd kisegítjük egymást
nekem is van kérdésem nekik is van
kérdésük és így erősítjük egymást hogy
mi az ami működik mi az ami nem na mint
ilyen tehát nem biztos hogy a több
ügyvédet kell megfogadni nyilván a
helyzet és a a az esetnek a komplexitása
a függvényében ezen is el kell
gondolkozni de a szakemberekkel kell
együtt dolgozni mert sokkal többet tud
az aki csak azon a területen dolgozik és
akkor te a jogi tudásodat rá tudod arra
húzni és tudod működtetni na most a te
esetedben nyilván nem adtam volna ezt a
tanácsot hogy ha nem győződők meg tehát
hogyha nekem kérdéseim vannak én azt is
elmondom hogy figyelj ezt lehet csinálni
a törvény megengedi de vállalod a
kockázatot tehát hogy azt is mindig úgy
gondolom hogy úgy korrekt hogy elmondodt
hogy ebben ez is ez a kockázat és a
kliens dönt na de az hogy az
adóhatósággal szemben nem lehet nyerni
ez nem igaz tehát hogy én biztos hogy
nyertem ellene nem is egyszer de az is
biztos hogy hoztak hozzám ügyet és
elmondtam hogy ezt nem lehet megnyerni
üüm igen tehát hogy
vannak helyzetek most is van folyamatban
perem az állami szervek ellen tehát hogy
régebb biztos hogy nehezebb volt pert
nyerni sőt az volt hogy hát per
költséget semmiképp ne kér mert hát azt
nem lehet hehát a költségvetésükben
nincsen benne na ma már ezek mennek
azért tehát az alap az hogy nem vállalod
fel azt amit még te is látsz tehát ami
hogy nem fog működni a te szűrődön nem
megy át akkor van az amikor azt mondod
hogy 50% az esély döntsd el megpróbálod
vagy nem próbálod meg mert van az amikor
van rajtad is fogás e ez nem fehér
fekete minden de az hogy rajtad fogás
van ugyebár az takargatod mindenkinek
van azért egy ákées sarka esetleg és ha
az nem kerül szóba akkor te szépen tudsz
haladni előre itt jön be az hogy
gondolkozz gondolkozz gondolkozol talán
miközben így meséltél azzal hogy ügyek
elhúzódnak a az előző mítosszal
kapcsolatban az merült fel hogy lehet
hogy jogilag nem is tudna nyerni az a
másik személy de tovább bírja tehát hogy
hogy ilyen lehetséges hogy valaki éveken
keresztül rádakaszt egy pert addig
görgeti addig húzza hogy te egyszerűen
elfáradsz az egészbe anyagilag
érzelmileg és ez emiatt fog nyerni lehet
de hát az ügyfél nem kell ott legyen
tehát ki ahogy ahogy mit tudom én a
fametsést kiadott valakinek munkába
intézze hát rám bízták az ügyet megyek
előre szólok hogyha kell valami vagy ha
baj van megegyeztünk ehhez tartom magam
ühüm felhívsz tájékoztatlak hát akkor ez
a fejemben ez is a fejemben egy mítosz
volt hogy ott kell legyek személyesen és
ogy érzelmileg ez meg a vóernél igen
mert az egy személyes kérdés összesem
adnak téged úgy hogy valaki más mondja
ki helyetted az igen tehát hogy vannak
ilyen személyes perk vagy személyes
helyzetek de egyébként azért van az
ügyvédet hogy menjen előre nagyon sokan
csalódottak azért hogy ott vagyunk és
nem is szól hozzánk a bíró hát persze
hogy nem szól hozza a bíró mert ott van
az ügyvédje és az ügyvédjével sokkal
gyorsabban és hatékonyabban
kommunikáligen úgyhogy ez így egyértelmű
hát hogyha persze biztos van az amikor
mi is elfelejtünk szólni hogy figyelj
itt vagy látják hogy jelen vagy de nem
fognak veled van néha amikor feltesznek
neki kis kérdést mert mit én a helyzet
úgy adja vagy valamire kíváncsi speciál
a bíró hogy otthon lesz-e holnapután
hogy menjenek nézzék meg mérék a az
ingatlant tehát ü arra én nem tudok
válaszolni üüm a titoktartásról tudnál
egy pár szót mondani hogy ezt egyrészt
mennyire nehéz vinni másnak a titkait és
van-e ilyen kivétel el tudnám képzelni
lenne egy kivétel annyira megbízol abb a
személyben hogy egyszerűen csak mint egy
pszichológus vagy mint egy társ akinek
el tudod mondani hogy a terheket átad
úgy tehát hogy te ezt hogyan éled meg az
ügyvédi titoktartás ez men ennyire egy
erős szabály nálad én ezt azzal szoktam
elviccelni hogy egy kicsit épp annyira
komoly ne legyek hogy a legjobb
titoktartó vagyok mert én elfelejtem
lazán te tényleg tehát hogy jönnek
mondják hogy ennyi évvel akár két évvel
ezelőtt ezt vagy azt csináltam és én
tényleg nem emlékszem tehát mivel mi
tényleg ennyi információval
jogszabállyal mindennel dolgozunk
lehetetlenség mindent ézben tartani ha a
feladatot én letudtam lezártam én
elfelejtem jótékony az agy nem lehet
ennyi mindent fejben tartani ühüm
viszont
azért történetek megmaradnak gondolom
természetesen
de valamit tényleg elfelejt az ember és
és jön az ügyfél utólag hogy mekkorát
segítettél neki egy bajában és te még
csak a nevére sem emlékszel az ügyfélnek
van ilyen szégyen nem szégyen de a
kapacitásunknak van határa mondja ezt
más kolléga is hogy tehát tényleg nincs
hova kötni az es igen vagy vagy annyi az
egyéb és az új ami éppen foglalkozhat ez
az egyik a másik az hogy tökéletesen
tisztában kell lenni azzal hogy lehetsz
te két lábon járó törvénykönyv mindent
tudhatsz lehet fantasztikus
gondolkodásod logikád mindenet lehet de
ha te nem tudsz titkot tartani akkor
neked a pályán előbb-utóbb tehát neked
nincs keresnivalód egyszerűen nem lesz
hog tehát éhen halsz ezt egyszer vagy
kétszer eljátszod de de annyi tehát hogy
ezt nem lehet és ezzel nagyon tisztában
kell lenni mindenkivel egyébként nekem
ez hog mondjam a jellememmel is nagyon
talál tehát hogy nálam ez e ez ez egy
annyira alap hogy én már idegesítő
vagyok ilyen szempontból viszont sajnos
vannak helyzetek
amikor és és ezt kell megértsék az
ügyfelek is hogy akármikor ha felhívnak
nem tudod fölvenni a telefont mert ő nem
tudja hogy ki hallja az én
beszélgetésemet vele igen tehát én nem
tudom fölvenni az egy dolog hogy nem
veszem fel mikor ügyféllel tárgyalok de
én nekem meg arra is kell vigyáznom hogy
ki hallja amikor én ott vagyok na most
természetesen sokszor van az hogy
például a gyerekeim ott vannak és h
na rájuk ugyanúgy vol vonatkozik a
titoktartás persze nem tudják hogy kivel
beszélek de hallanak dolgokat és ez
például ott derül ki hogy most egy
ici-pici kitérő hogy én tartok
foglalkozást a nagyobbik fiam
osztálytársainak ugy egy pár gyermeknek
és az én gyerekem rettenetesen undja
mert egy csomó mindent tud mert kiderült
hogy én már az ő szemében sok mindent
ismételek mert akaratlanul szegényre ez
ragad rá ez hallja otthon is akár közben
h
igen ez a szándéka egyelőre vagy még a
bíróságon is gondolkozik de hogy hogy
úgy nem lehet titkot tartani hogyha
tehát hogyha még erre is kell figyeljünk
nálam ez ez tényleg annyira alap annyira
akár van aki ezért ezért meg is
haragszik hogy de tőlem senki nem
várhatja el hogy én hogy én beszéljek
egyébként a a barátaim tehát azok akik
közel állnak hozzám nem is érdekli őket
tudják tehát hogy engem így kell
elfogadni akármennyire érdekes számodra
valami én biztos hogy nem fogok róla
beszélni de ezt meg tudom erősíteni
viszont hogy ez bizalmat szű tehát az
hogyha nemet mondasz valakinek ott lehet
hogy helybe úgy tűnik mint hogyha ha
csalódást okoztál volna annak a
személynek de az azemély tudja hogy te
nem fogsz más hes másnak sem így van így
van
hát ha már ezt felosztad igen ez volt
egy érdekes ugye a hogy megjelent ufó
ahogy megpróbálta kikezdeni ilyen
szempontból a hitelességemet na most
persze hogy zavart engem úgy akkor mert
hogy az amit leírtunk hát minden
leellenőrző tehát én szopva vagyok ahhoz
hogy az én szövegeimet szétszedik én így
élek tehát amit én leírok az nagyon nagy
jól védhető kell legyen és az hogy ő ő
felhozta ezt hogy én bizalommal éltem
volna vissza ugyan nem mondta ki de de
szépen próbálta ab igen igen sugalta
hogy hogy én titkot sértettem meg hát
ugye bántott a dolog de végeredményben
hozzám jöttek és mondták hogy tehát aki
az ő írásait olvass hát ő maga írja ezt
le hogy ő az emaileket hogy nyitja meg
tehát az nem volt egy olyan inform az
már eleve nyilvános információ volt
mielőtt én azt a pert felvállaltam volna
én ezt pontos tudtam akkor amikor ezt
leírtam mert hogy megvizsgáltam mert
tehát ez a másik része mikor eszedbe jut
egy információ tehát ezért gondolkozunk
mi sokat ami ugye nem feltűnő mikor
ezedben itt egy információ akkor te azon
el kell gondolkozz hogy te azt honnan
tudod merth hogy sok tehát hogy mondjam
tényleg baráti társaságoknak egyenként
dolgozol teljesen más ügyében és nem
hiszem hogy létezne ember aki el tudná
azt mondani hogy én az egyiknek a
másikról bármit is mondtam csak a témát
hogy miben dolgozok ha az ügyfél nem
hozza fel én arról nem beszélhetek és
nem is beszélek nekem ez nem gond én
örülök hogyha nem kell a beszéljek
ezekről tehát hogy mondjam nekem elég az
ami van nem érzem ennek igényét úgyhogy
nálam ez egy szerencsés találkozás igen
ez ez ez ez amúgy ilyen ilyen
szempontból egy jó tanács is lehet az
embereknek hogy miért ne hazudjanak mert
felmerül a kérdés felmerül a kérdés hogy
miért ne hazudjunk hogyha ha tudjuk hogy
megússzuk ha tudjuk hogy garantáltan
akkor akkor mi ne hazudjunk és a válasz
erre az hogy abban a pillanatban miely
itt valaki hazudik a realitás a a a
valóság struktúráját elkezdi hajlítani
és abban a pillanatban két történetet
észbe kell tartson a saját történetét
ami az igazság és a hazugság és akkor
utána viszont el kell mind a két
történet el kell kezdje éltetni de egy
idő után nem fogja tudni egy idő után
már összetéveszti a hazugságot az
igazsággal és és elkerülhetetlen a bukás
j van tehát én még a realitás én még a
valóságra sem emlékszem azt mondtam mer
hogy emlékezzek még a hazugságra is
tehát hogy egyszerűen ez lehetetlen és
akkor ugye vannak az embernek saját
szabályai amivel belőv ezeket hogy nem
tud tévedni igen mert hogy például
mindig előtte vizsgál meg hogy az az
információ neked honnan honnan jönigen
az én
titkárnőmreüm ugyanígy áll ez és ő ezt
nagyon jól tudja úgy programálok
ügyfeleket hogy ha lehet ne
találkozzanak ü ezekre oda kell figyelni
szerintem persze ez nem jelenti azt hogy
nincs úgy hogy nem találkoznak de
igyekszem tehát hogy ha tetszik ez az
epizód akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra vagy írd meg kommentbe hogy
milyen más témáról hallanál még szívesen
a következő téma amiről egy kicsit
beszél beszélgetnék említetted az előbb
hogy a te tanárod javasolta és mondta
hogy egy egy ez az ügyvédi szakmához egy
egészséges test kell egy egészséges
emberke
igen
gyanítom hogy valaki 19 éven keresztül
ami amik ügyvéd voltál eddig azért
voltak pillanatok n nem lehett valaki
egészséges 19 éven keresztül voltak
nehéz pillanatok voltál szülési
szabadságon
kicsit mesélnél-e arról hogy hogyan küzd
meg egy ügyvéd akkor amikor nincs jól
mikor nincs
jól hát én szerintem ez ez nem az
ügyvédségemből fakadó dolog a nem az én
mesterem volt hanem a barátnőm mester
aki azt mondja hogy ide ide csak ép
épészel lehet jönni igen tehát én úgy
gondolom hogy amíg egészségünk van addig
erőnk van és addig megtehetünk dolgokat
mikor egészségügyi problémák lépnek fel
akkor akkor az nagyon-nagyon kemény mert
tehetetlen vagy na most nekem nem az
adatott meg hogy én ek beteg hanem az én
nagyfiamat betegen szültem tehát hogy ő
ő eleve betegen született ami megengedte
hogy beszéljek róla és azért is
beszélnék róla hogy hogy az emberek
tudják vagy vagy nem tudom hogyha
valakit ez érdekel
hogy hogy van remény tehát a rákból fel
lehet gyógyulni na most én én daganatos
betegséggel szültem meg somát ami azt
jelenti hogy egy fantasztikus nőgyógyász
észrevette de a terhességem utolsó két
hetében hogy sajnos az egyik vesén van
egy egy daganat és ez már ugye azt
jelentette hogy itt nem lehetett le ez
ráadásul ez december 27-én volt tehát
akkor amikor a nem hogy a fű nem nő de
hogy orvoscsapatot nem tudsz összeszedni
hogy a gyermeket fogják ki és azonnal
amit szükséges tegyenek meg és hát nekem
ugye nagy szerencsém van mertogy az én
nővérem az gyerekorvos úgyhogy az ő
segítségével csapatott itt romániában
akkor még te hát 17 éve 16 éve nem
lehetett összeszedni úgyhogy nekünk
szegedre kellett menni úgyhogy én
szegeden is szültem és ugyan tehát hogy
ez azzal járt emlékszem mondtam a a
doktornak hogy de hát nem lehetne mégis
azt a vesét megmenteni mert én tudom
hogy kettő van de hogy de hogy azért
azért nem lehet tudniá csak úgy vegyék
le a daganatot s akkor ugye fel se
fogott tát nekem nem volt azelőtt
ilyennel dolgom és mondta emlékszem hog
nagyon-nagyon kioózanító volt mondta a
professzor hogy asszonyom értse meg
ennek ez a gyógymódja veséstől megy és
akkor én ezt megértettem és és sokszor
eszembe jutt mert én ugyanígy egy ilyen
mondattal helyre kell tegyem az ügyfelet
hogy én értem hogy ő nagy bajban van
merát nagy bajban van de kell az a
kijózanító mondat itt itt ugye
visszatérve az objektivitásra hogy én
azt meg kell őrizzem nagyon sajnálak
biztos engem is sajnáltak de a bes se
megy és hát igen kemény kemény dolgok
ezek hogy írjál alá egy csomó mindent és
fogalmad sincs hogy a gyermek hogy fog
reagálni mire allergiás hát é semmit nem
tudunk mert semmijen nem volt na hát hát
túl voltunk ezen viszont az volt a gond
hogy egy három hónapos kontrollkor
kiderült hogy egy pingpong labda van a a
kivett vese helyén úgyhogy ott már
visszaeső harmadik stádium tehát
kemoterápia és mondták hogy hát
ekkorájuk még nem volt mert hát ép úgy
szülött nem volt de hogy csecsemő volt
és mireire az egy évet be töltötte
addigra túl voltunk egy kilenc hónapos
kemoterápián annak minden velejárójával
nagyon nagy küzdelem volt és
természetesen én ezt a gyermeket nagyon
akartam tehát hát hogy nem csak én más
is de hogy az ember ilyenkor elkezd
gondolkozni azon hogy hogy tarthatnám
meg
és én én nem tudok tenni a daganatos
betegségek ellen viszont azt tudom hogy
az erős immunitás igen és nekem innen
jön ez az egészségtudatosság és én
azelőtt is tehát az egyetem alatt én
grehem kenyeret ettem mert ott lehetett
kapni itt még nem lehetett kapni tehát a
grhem kenyér ugye az egy orvos egy
dietetikus orvosnak a receptje alapján
készült kenyér nem fehér kenyér nem
fehérlíz tehát én azért figyeltem
dolgokra már az előtt is sőt a
terhességem alatt is de így jártunk és
sajnos úgy tűnik hogy az én édesanyám
vonala az ilyen egyenesági daganat
örökítés van vagy mindenképp erős a
hajlamunk na hát ez így engem átugrott
és és a fiam lett beteg és én ezt
olvastam tehát ennek jártam utána hogy
én hogy tudom életben tartani a
gyermekes ezt úgy értsd hogy életben
tartom én hát persze ott volt az a sok
orvos akik örök hálámü üldözi az
összeset tehát hogy a meg az
ápolószemélyzet tehát hogy hogy
fantasztikus nagy dolgokat tudnak ők
tenni de hogy mi az amit én meg tudok
tenni mert ezt az egészet én úgy tudtam
elviselni vagy vagy úgy voltam képes
túlélni hogy én nem vagyok tehetetlen
nekem ezt meg kellett élni hogy én mit
tudok hozzátenni a gyógyulásához az
igazsághoz az is hozzá tartozik hogy
elmondták hogy ez gyógyítható csak ki
kell bírni ki kell bírni azt hogy a kemó
legyengíti az immunitást és egy egyszerű
átha vagy egy egyszerű kicsi apró
banális vírus elviszi mert nem tud
megküzdeni vele tehát onnantól fogva én
karanténban voltam ami azt jelenti hogy
én még boltba se jártam ha nem volt
muszáj vagy befutottam kifutottam
úgyhogy ehhez képest nekem a covid
karanténja pipeepurc volt őszintén tehát
az az elzártság meg az ahogy ahogy megün
kellett karanténba hát
ugye kilenc hónapos volt a kemo úgyhogy
utána még egy darabig mert utána még egy
szívműtét is várt rá na szóval hogy de
nem volt nagy szívműtét ugyát az
orvosoknak az rutinszerű volt nekünk
kevésbé de de túléltük tehát egy kicsit
olyan olyan erősre sikeredett a kezdés
és és én akkor ennek olvastam utána hogy
jó hogyha ebből ki kijövünk akkor mit
adjak neki enni mivel tudok a az erős
immunitásról gondoskodni és akkor az
egyik ugye a jó kedv tehát hogy kell egy
egy stabil nyugodt légkör igen is kell
örülni mármint hogy mondjam ez azért
most hy igen is kell örülni
tudod tudatosan figyeljünk erre mert a
stressz főleg az én munkámmal járó
stressz az nem
kiköszöbölhető viszont tudjam megadni a
gyermekemnek azt hogy hogy jelen vagyok
nem azt mondom hogy mindig meg van olyan
leszolos hozzá meg tudják ők is tehát
hogy de amblok tehát hogy úgy
összességében keressük azt hogy ne
erőltessek olyasmit például amiről tudom
hogy neki az nem jó figyeljek rá másképp
és jobban ez valószínűleg így is úgy is
megtörtént volna de így nagyon tudatossá
vált plusz az étkezés tehát nálunk van
egy ilyen szogán hogy szar nemeszünk
fiam és és akkor így ebből tehát úgy hog
mondjam junk food satöbbi ez nem jelenti
azt hogy néha nem mert nem lehet
teljesen tiltani de beosztással és és
nagyon odafigyelve arról hogy mi mi
honnan származik ilyen szempontból
udvarhely egy nagyon-nagyon jó hely mert
be lehet szerezni tehát mindenféle
kapcsolatainim vannak hogy mikor van
kacsahús mikor van marhahús vagy
borjúhús vagy bármit hogy mikor vágnak
nekem a piacon megmondják hogy ez kapott
vegyszert vagy nem kapott vegyszert
tehát hogy hogy ki lehet ez igen is ki
lehet építeni é kell és akkor én így
remélem azt hogy hogy a gyermeke
egészséges marad vagy elég erős lesz
hogyha bt a mengű hogy hogy megharcoljon
azóta tiszta igen igen nem nem volt
vissza nem mondom hogy nem voltak
ijedségeink időnként de de azért mindig
vaklármának bizonyult hál istennek és és
nagyon jól van és nagy örömünk van benne
úgyhogy de hogy nagy dolgok ezek és hogy
igenis van élet tehát hogy hogy bele
kell menni ezekbe a harcokba ezekbe a
krízisekbe végig kell csinálni és tudod
nem mondták hogy túléli azt mondták hogy
nagyon nagy az esélye ühüm és és én
tudtam hogy arról én tehetek vagyis hogy
én oda hahatok hogy ő őt ne kap tehát
vírus ne lásson és így tovább ebben a
ebben az
időszakban és minden nap boldog voltam
tehát nem hiszed el hogy egy gyermek
onkológia osztályon mennyi öröm van hogy
hogy mennyire tudunk örülni annak hogy
ez a nap így lejárt és majd a holnap
nehézségeinek és kihívásainak megyünk
elébe és végigcsináljuk de mi hogy ez a
mai nap lejárt úgy hogy nem vérzett be
nem kellett ezt vagy azt csinálni benne
maradt az étel tehát hogy hogy az valami
hihetetlen hogy hogy látod azt mikor
valamit elveszítenél amúgy is amúgy is
nő az értéke nem tehát tényleg a
szomjuságot a sivatagban sokkal jobban
vagy a vizet sokkal jobban értékeled a
sivatagban nem
és és én úgy voltam vele hogy ha el kell
veszítsem akkor legalább ne úgy éljek
hogy amíg vele lehettem nem használtam
ki tehát hogy akkor és én így élek tehát
hogy hogy a mindennapokat nem azt mondom
hogy nem viszel néha de de heti szinten
mindenképp hogy megélni hogy jelen lenni
hogy felfogni azt hogy vow hogy hogy
nekünk mennyi minden megadatott hogy mi
élhetünk hát nekem az volt a vágyam
mikor mikor azért kellett vinni levegőre
iss hogy a friss levegő is nagyon fontos
az egészség szempontjából is és hát
láttam ott ősz is megértük szegeden hogy
hogy gesztenyét szednek nagy örömmel a
gyerekek az anyukákkal és hogy én nem
tudom hogy mi fogunk-e gesztenyét szedni
és hát el tudod képzelni hogy minden
gesztenyének én hogy örülök hogy kiró
számra mi is vittük haza azután amikor
lehetett átértékelődnek és és és tudjuk
értékelni a a mindennapokban mindezt
másképp milyen szép ez
a ez amit érzek benned ami kihat nyilván
az ügyvédi munkádra is de anyaként is és
lehet hogy mindjárt áttérünk a a a civil
életedre is ez a proaktivitás ez nem nem
egy magától értetődő gondolat hogy hogy
az ember képes proaktív lenni mert
valójában mélyebb gondolat mögötte az
hogy szabadok vagyunk pontosan és mi a
mert a szabadságnak viszont ára van hüüm
és azok az emberek akik tehát egy
kommunizmust túléltünk és és egy
posztkommunista világban élünk
ető a különbség köztünk és a nyugatiak
között én amikor beszélgettem a az
egyetemen a munkatársaimmal meg más
cégvezetőkkel érezhető hogy másképp
nőttek fel belink plántálódott az
áldozatmentalitás hogy mi áldozatok
vagyunk legalábbis én ebbe így nőttem
fel nincs ilyen na ezt mondom benem a
szikrány áldozat tényleg nincs igen ez
viszont semmi ez viszont nem jellemző a
az á tehát ilyen szempontból te egy
kirívó személy vagy hogy valamiért
ilyen ezt a ezt az igazságot megértetted
ezt a bölcsességet hogy tudunk tenni és
milyen szép hogy hogy hogyan harcoltatok
együtt és minden nap azt nézed hogy mi
az amit még ma meg tudok tenni igen ez
eg ez egy nagy üzenet hogy számomra és
én én a én mondom neked hogy én nem volt
tehát a 20-as éveimre emlékszem a 20as
éveim elejére főleg az érettségi utáni
első pár évre amikor abszolút
áldozatként éltem tényleg igen tehát a a
a más volt a hibás mindig azért amit én
teszek és
és és rájönni arra hogy valójában én
vagyok felelős én vagyok felelős az
akkori kapcsolatomba szakítottunk és én
vagyok felelős érte vagy én vagyok
felelős azért hogy mikor kelek fel én
vagyok felelős nem volt természetes és
valójában a kommunizmus is ezt hozta
tehát a kommunizmus alatt a a a az
emberek megkapták azt a komfortot hogy
biztonságot kapnak és a felelősséget
elviszik elveszik tőle de cserébe
cseriben diktatúra van cseriben
megmondják hogy mit kell gondolj mit
merre kell és ez történik sokszor a a
egy vagy egy munkahelyen is
én érzem mint vezető hogy ez az egyik fő
alapelv amit amit élnünk kell a cégben
hogy mindenki felelős és mindenki szabad
a szabadságnak ára van viszont jó dolog
szabadnak a felnőttek szabadok a
gyermekek azok akik dependensek a
szüleiktől meg kell tanulják azt hogy
hogyan legyenek proaktívak az hogy te
proaktívvá váltál és neked ennyire
természetes én azért kíváncsi vagyok
hogy te vissza tudod-e tapogatni így az
életedben hogy honnan jön ez a ez a ez a
fajta abszolút bizonyosság hogy te vagy
felős mindenért ami az életedben
történik és tehetsz dolgokat persze
tehát én én látod ezt nem így nem egy
formán látjuk én nem semmilyen rendszer
függvényt nem látok ebben bár lehet hogy
így van az is lehet hogy nekem a a
családomban a barátaim között tehát azok
akik tényleg közel állnak hozzám én nem
ismerek áldozatot tehát egyik sem
áldozat én én nem soha nem beszélgetünk
szerintem nem is lennénk barátok lehet
mertogy én ezt az áldozat típust ezt
valószínűleg taszítjuk egymás ühüm
ühümehát hog le bosszant is hogyha
valakit igen én ezzel nem is tudok mit
kezdeni hát mozdulj meg hát mi van hát
megteheted mi az akadálya a saját
magunknak hát azért csak azért látod
hogy az emberek sokszor reaktívan
fogalmaznak hogy el kell menjek meg ezt
kell csinálnom és ennek az áldozata
vagyok tehát a nyelvünk nyelvi szinten
is bennünk van ez v lehet hogy én a kel
mögött nem áldozatiságot látok van
dolgot tedd meg kész tehát hogy én én
nem tehát elmehetsz mer ha akarsz
elmehetsz igen a döntés mindig amien de
szerintem ezt otthonról hozzuk tehát ez
szülő kérdése ühüm és az én szüleim nem
voltak áldozatok tehát soha nem volt
áldozatgondolkodásuk és
és szerintem nem tudom most a te szüleid
milyenek de hogy szerintem ez onnan jön
ühüm
nekem mindig tevékenyek voltak a a
szüleim én én megkaptam azt az érzelmi
biztonságot igen ezen múlik minden
vagyis hogy hogy nagyon sok minden mert
korrigálat ótólag valamelyes de hogyha
az megvan szinte minden megvan üüm belső
szabadságot ad hát gyanítom a fiúk akkor
akkor a vérükben van a proaktivitás hogy
hogy bízom benne bízon benne változó ha
akarják élnek a jogaikkal ha akarják
akkor igen de amit ők akarnak
kivitelezni azt ők kivitelezik néha
egész meglepő módon teljesen más
megoldásokat találva de én ezt
nagyon-nagyon élvezem kell vitatkozzunk
természetesen hát mégis csak kamaszodnak
de de én örülök nekik üüm örülök inkább
mint hogy én kell ilen jöjjek az
ötletekkel é hogy miért nem és hogy nem
nagyon érdekes ahogy a világra
rácsodálkozom nyílik a szemük
élvezem hát örülök hogy azóta sok
geszenyét szetettetek és remélem nagyon
sok geszényét fogtok még szedni ez ezek
ez ez a tapasztalás szinte könnyeket is
hoztál a szemem ez a tapasztalás ez
tényleg egy olyan valóság amit az elmúlt
pár évben én is így kóstolgatok hogy
valójában vékony jégen járunk
mindannyian hogy bármikor beszakadhat az
a jég és alattunk a végtelen mélység az
a bizon osság az a biztonság az nem egy
garantált dolog senki sem tudja
meghosszabbítani könyöknyivel az életét
ahogy írja a az evangéliumba és és ez
tényleg így van hogy hogy ki az aki
garantálja nekünk hogy holnap élünk de
viszont nem ez az érzetünk na legalábbis
gyakran belefeledkezek és és gyakran ez
a szégyenérzet vagy ez a a
a eszembe jut hogy most figyelhettem
volna jobban a gyermekeimre m most ebben
a pillanatban most andrás öt éves vagy
négy éves és és és ha ezt most nem
jegyzem meg amúgy sokszor elfelejtem a
pillanatokat az igazság nem tudom meg
meg megmarkolni a az emlékeket akkor
elveszítem úgyhogy
úgyhogy ezt köszönöm neked ezt a
történetet tehát én nem azt mondtam hogy
azért remélem hogy nem ez jött le hogy
én aztán tudé végz é hogy mindig csak
hogy hogy keresem ezt hogy ma legalább
ez sikerült ma ma tudtunk együtt jelenni
ma jelen voltam ma hogy is mondjam
értékelni azt amink van sokszor azt
látom hogy mi hajszolunk valamit a a
jövőt a jövőbeni dolgokat és közben nem
vesszük észre hogy hát gyakorlatilag
annyi mindenünk van abszolút hietetlenül
gazdagok vagyunk és amúgy az jellemző az
elmúlt tehát a a az emberiség
történelmében ilyen gazdagok nem voltunk
soha én sem élnék máskorban nem azt
mondom hogy
hogy hogy minden tökéletes most de most
van a legtöbb lehetőségünk de ezzel az
élettel is hogy azt mondod hogy
hogy ma ma élünk és holnap nem de én ma
mindent megteszek hogy hosszú életem
legyen és ne úgy legyen hosszú életem
hogy hogy itt fáj meg ott fáj tehát ez
munka menj el tornász nézd meg hogy mit
eszel tartsd magad
tartsd
magad karban legyen ez kezeld úgy magad
minth a kedvelnéd magad hát azt szoktam
mondani hogy ha én nem szeretem magam
akkor ki szeressen üüm ha még én se ez
persze nem azt jelenti hogy hondyom az
ember nem szeretjük elfogadni vagy
elismerni de hát muszáj szeressem magam
hogyha meg akarok lenni magamban
magammal tehát hogy
és ez nem jelenti azt hogy hogy mondjam
nem más ellenében szereted magad de ha
nem tanulod meg magadat elfogadni a
helyzetedet akkor akkor mástól mit vársz
el abszolút meg más sem fogsz tudni te
jól szeretni tehát hogyha ez ezt y
praktikusan is fel lehet fogni tehát
hogy nincs olyan hogy most létezik kata
mer van kata és van a jövőbeli kata és
öt év múlva levő kata és a 10 év múlva
levő kata de valójában úgy kell szeresd
magad hogy a környezetednek is jó legyen
és a városnak is jó legyen és az
országnak is jó legyen mert egyszerre
kell ez az egész hierarchia működjön és
valójában nincs különbség ak között hogy
a jövőbeli katát szereted-e vagy mást
szeretsz a jelen pillanatban tehát hogy
úgy kell éld az életedet hogy figyelsz a
környezetedre hogy egy közösség vagyunk
mert a jövőbeli kata is egy közösség
bizonyos szempontból egyszerre a a
következő 30 4050 évben amennyi amennyi
még adatott neked egy közösséget kell
egyszerre jól szeress úgyhogy egy
elveket kell kövess ebbe hogy hogyan
hogyan szereted jól magad amibe a
testedet is jól szereted de az
intellektusodat is jól szereted a köz a
az érzelmi kapcsolataidat is megpróbálod
erősíteni és megpróbálsz egy értelmes
életet élni amiért érdemes felkelni nap
mint nap ezt látom hogy így ez ezt
jelenti azt hogy magadat jól szereted
igen meg elfogadni azt hogy vannak
hiányosságok vannak gyengeségek egy
csomó de há istennek van egyéb is tehát
nem kell én mindenhez értsek nem kell én
megszereljem az autómat nem kell én mit
ne csináljak nem kell én tudjak
előállítani dolgokat kell tudjam azt
hogy ki az az ember aki ezt nekem meg
tudja csinálni úgyhogy én bízok benne
hát én nagyon örvendek hogy hogy jogász
lettél hogy ügyvéd vagy mert ehhez
értesz és ha bármilyen jogi segítségre
van szükségem az egyből te leszel akit
fel fogok keresni apropó felkeresni még
ezt meg szerettem volna kérd az előző
témával kapcsolatban hogy mikor keressen
valaki
ügyvédet van-e egy általános
tapasztalatod ezzel kapcsolatban hogy
hogy van-e valami ami alapján
felismerheti valaki mert sokszor tűrnek
az emberek
sokszor próbálnak reménykednek és akkor
mikor mikor van az a pont amikor azt
mondják hogy azt kell hogy mondják hogy
üyvédet keresnek nekem ha elromlik az
autóm én elviszem a
szerelőhöz ha tudom hogy az olaj az
olajat kell cserélni vagy ellenőrizni
vagy akármit csinálni v az egy prevenció
nem elviszem megoldják nem várom meg még
leég a motrom vagy most lehet hogy
hülyeséget mondtam mert nem értek hozzá
de
tehát prevenció tehát hogy én mind
várhatok reménykedhetek a csodába csak
nem tudom hogy miben tehát hogy ott
látom né hogy van egy sebbe a lábamon de
nem kezelem aztán már üszkösödik de még
mindig bízok a jóistenben van az a vicc
hogy a jóisten küldi a létrát a repülőt
a helikoptert mindent küld de te bízol a
jóistenben és várod hogy akkor majd lesz
valami tehát hogy neked is tehát
aktívnak kell lenned oda kell figyelni
természetesen mikor most már azért egyre
többen jönnek és megkérdeznek mielőtt
cselekednének mert nagyon sokszor tudok
segíteni egy egyszerű tanácsadás hogy
abba a szerződésbe még ezt is ezt ted
bele azért hogy az téged védjen vagy
például azért kicsit a titoktartást is
érinti visszatérek mikor annak idején
megkérdezték tőlem hogy na ma mit
dolgoztál és hog mondtam hogy mit én
adtam egy tanácsot válóperben tehát hogy
ez ez most pont a az én párom ügyvéd
volt tehát hogy ő értette is hogy mit
jelent az tehát hogy a nehézségét hogy
most egy válóperben t adni nem egy
kihívás ühüm és esetleg hogyha így
megemlítettem akkor neki az volt az első
reakciója hogy na és kibékülnek tehát
hogy hogy mondjam a válást is meg kell
gondolni olyan értelemben hogy persze
döntést úgy hozd meg hogy tudjad hogy mi
következik azután mert a válás csak egy
papír ugyanúgy ahogy a házasság is tud
csak egy papír lenni hogyha nem töltöd
meg tartalommal na most egy válásnál is
kell tudjad azt hogy hogy most ez van ez
nem tetszik de lehet hogy ami jön egy
válással az se fog tetszeni ühüm tehát
te döntéshelyzetben vagy el kell döntsd
hogy hogy mi legyen és hogy legyen de
hogy hozzál döntést hogyha te nem vagy
tájékozottüüm hova kellene elmenjél
tájékozódni valakihez aki ért hozza de
hát ugyanez van én kurálhatom magam
c-vitaminnal tüdőgyulladás esetén nem
igen és és így tovább számomra döbbenet
az hogy a facebookon a kis a a kismamák
anyukák a a szomszédok mindenki tanácsot
ad hogy tehát kérdés szerintetek ilyen
piros ft jelent meg le is fényképezi a
gyermekemnek itt és ott felejtsük el a
gyermeknek a személyiségi jogait vagy a
magánélethez való jogát mi lehet ez én
tudom mert tavaly nekem is ilyen volt
pont az lehet ezzel és ezzel a kenőccsel
kenegettem ühüm megáll az eszem miért
nem megy orvoshoz jaj hogy az orvosra
sokat kell várni de hát annak van a
kezében a válasz ühüm tehát hogy hog
mondjam nem jó sorb állsz hogyha te a
kenyeres sorbálsz kenyeret fogsz kapni
de tejet nem igen hát ez az
adóoptimizálás kapcsolatban abszolút
éreztem hogy hogy ide jó helyre jókor
jöttem és és hogy hogy jó kezekben
vagyok tehát hogy ezt ezt hiába nézném
facebook csoportokon hogy hogy hogyan
lehet igen igen vagy vagy olyanon aki
aki csak műveli de nem nincs mögötte
tartalom tehát hogy hogy hogy is mondjam
ma már mindenki mindenhez is ért semmi
gond én én értem csak csak akkor a a
válasz is az tehát hogy annyit kapsz
pont annyit kapsz na de eltértem a
témától tehát a kérdés az az volt hogy
mikor forduljon ügyvédhez valaki igen
igen tehát érdemes hogyha egy jogi
problémában kérdése van azt inkább
feltenni természetesen itt jön a az egy
kérdés esete kata csak egy egy kérdésem
van rám írnak vagy sincs egy kérdés
sincs egy kérdés mert ahhoz hogy én
neked felelősségteljesen választ tudjak
adni én meg kell értsem a körülményeit
annak a helyzetnek gondoljunk egy
adásvételi szerződésre ha te vevő vagy
vagy ha te eladó vagy teljesen másra
kell odafigyelni egy szerződés kötés
esetében ezt nem tudom azt mondom hogy
persze lehet a törvény megengedi de
téged az nem segít mert az csak egy
általános válasz hogyha te konkrétumot
akarsz kellismeriem a konkrét
helyzetedet és akkor nincsen csak egy
kérdés és ezen megsértődnek pedig
felelőtlenség lenne a részemről egy
kérdésre választ adni arra az egy kérdés
valóban hogy ugye ahogy azt írja a
törvénykönyv hogy senkit nem tartanak
házasságban akarata ellenére hogy
maradjunk ennél a példánás annak
válaszolok hogy igen és ez egy kérdés
volt de ez nagyon-nagyon ritka ühüm na
most
amit én nagyon nagyon nagyon sajnálok az
az hogy a törvény azt mondja hogy 18 év
felett senki nem mentesül azért vagy
azzal nem nem nem kifogásként nem
felhozható hogy te nem tudtad nem
ismerted a jogszabályt tehát
gyakorlatilag a törvényhozó azt
feltételezi hogy te minden jogszabályt
tudsz na nincs olyan ügyvéd bíró
jogalkotó parlamenter bárki aki minden
jogszabályt tudna ez egyértelmű mégis ez
az elvárás miért ez az elvárás mert
hanem mindenki ezzel a kifogással jönne
és senkin nem lehetne semmit számon
kérni soha senki nem vállalna semmilyen
jellegű felelősséget tehát ez a szabály
nem rossz ez ez ugyanaz mint amikor a
katonák azt mondják hogy parancsra
cselekedtem ez már nem lehet egy kifogás
egy adott atrocitás után igen igen tehát
az is egy egy külön helyzet amiről
lehetne itt órákat beszélni viszont itt
behoznék nem tudom hogy még valamit
mondanál-e ezzel kapcsolatban mond
tekintettel arra hogy fogytál az időnk
egy kicsit rátérnék a közösségi
oldaladra is ugyanis
talán emiatt is most most tapogatózom
hogy hogy a törvény nem ismerete nem
mentesít minket a felelősség alól emiatt
gondolom hogy emiatt is jársz iskolákba
és segíted az alap alapokat elmagyarázni
a
diákoknak de nem csak ez a az egyik
közösségi tevékenységed van tehát az
szk-nál a székely udvarhelyi közösségi
alapítványnak a tagja voltál és aztán az
elnöke is hosszú ideig most
2022-be léptél kide gyakorlatilag 2014
óta a tagja vagy
és és ott van a gyermekeinkért mozgalom
amiről tudom hogy egy kicsit kell
beszéljünk mert egy fontos kezdeményezés
de azt is láttam hogy ugyanahogy az
ignisz mint oktatási központ egy
közösségi kezdeményezés már egyből volt
egy egy szinergia kösszünk és és láttam
hogy fontos számodra a közösség ami
megint hasonló a proaktivitáshoz nem
magától értetődő habár lehet neked az de
nem magától értetődő hogy egy szervezet
vagy valaki ak akar tenni a közösségért
pláne egy cég akar tenni egy közösségért
pláne a te üvédi irodád is felajánl
ilyen
ilyen segítségeket szóval
járjuk körbe ezeket a a témákat
kezdhetjük például azzal a
kezdeményezéssel amivel iskolákba jársz
középiskolákb ha jól értettem és és
órákra mész be és és felvilágosítást
tartasz jogi felvilágosítást
igazából ezek a tehát nem tudom én az
alapokat letenni egy óra alatt diákoknak
akik
akiket éppen vagy nem érdekel vagy
érdekel ugye fontos az élmény ha élményt
adsz akkor úgy jobban tanul vagy
könnyebben tanul az ember és én próbálom
ezt élménnyel játékokkal társítani hogy
minimálisan legalább egy
gondolkodásmódot mutassak be neki az az
úgy túlzás lenne hogy én bármilyen
alapot is tudnék adni de alapdolgokat
mondok inkább maradjunk inkább így
fogalmaznék ez nekem fontos azért mert
egyrészt védi őket tehát hogy hogy ezek
elvárt dolgok és bele lehet bukni csak
mert nem tudod hát nézzük meg a
mindennapokban tehát miért vannak perek
miért miért alakulnak úgy a dolgok hogy
miért félünk csak azért mert meghalljuk
hogy aná ha valamit megismerünk akkor
már nem félünk annyira ez így van és én
ezt a saját bőrömön tapasztaltam
betegségtől kezdve vagy bármitől tehát
hogy menj nézd meg merülj alá ismerd meg
tudod kezelni ha nem tudod kezelni
legalább tudod azt hogy az a valami
amitől te félsz hol kezdődik és hol
végződik és ez egy igenis egy segítség
mert onnantól fogva már megnyílik az
útja annak hogy kezeld valamilyen módon
onnantól fogva már nem szorongsz úgy már
már sokkal könnyebb az életed na most én
ilyenkor amikor bemegyek
játszunk ahogy lehet próbálom ha a
demokráciáról hívnak meg éppen akkor
merthogy ez tananyag akkor akkor a
demokráciáról beszélek ugye lebontva
hogy ez népakaratot jelentés és úgy
egyáltalán licitre bocsátom a az
alapvető jogokatm hogy gyakorlatilag
addig amíg elgondolkoznak és
fajsúlyozzák hogy melyik j jogra fognak
licitálni addigra már információkat
szereznek mert valami alapján döntenek
tehát igazából azzal hogy ők
gondolkoznak a témában én nem is kell
megszólaljak szinte mert ők maguk
nagyon-nagyon sokat tudnak igen igen
igen hogyha megkérdezem azt hogy van-e
nekik méltóságuk tudják hogy van
méltóságuk de nem nem biztos hogy meg
tudják fogalmazni hogy mi az na most
ezek az alkalmak azok amikor egy picit
így feldolgozzuk és körbejárjuk a témát
hogy igenis az emberi méltóságot ilyen
vagy olyan módon védi a törvény hogy az
mi az hogy van neked hogy neked van a
másiknak van-e hogy hogy kedj úgy hogy
ne sértsd meg a másik méltóságát és ha
megsérted az mivel jár tehát hogy
kibontunk egy-egy témát ahogy ahogy
adódik én ebben örömömet lelem tehát
örömömet lelem mert átadnak ők is egy
gondolkodást amit én nem ismerek és
nagyon érdekes számomra hogy hogy mit
hogy közelítenek meg és másrészt pedig
úgy gondolom hogy felelősségünk ha
minden szülő bemenne egy picit a
gyerekek közé a saját gyerekével a
kapcsolata erősödik mertogy látja a ugye
nem csak otthon a a kinyúl nadrágban meg
pólóban látja egy fakanállal a kezében a
az anyját hanem látja úgy is hogy van
egy szakma amit valamilyen szempontból
művel valamilyen szinten művel és hogy
kicsit jobban megismeri a saját anyját
én mint anya egy kicsit jobban
megismerhetem a fiamat a fiamnak a
társaságát ahova bejár és ahol minimum
nem tudom hat-8olc órát eltölt hát ez ha
ezt felismerjük akkor tulajdonképpen egy
csomó mindent a kortársorientációtól
elkezdve tudnánk kezelni ami egy súlyos
probléma tud lenni hogyha nem én vagyok
a a gyermekemnek az aki után vagy akivel
ő tud
orientálódniüm a hiányok az hogy
droghasználat az hogy képernyőhasználat
alkohol bármi jelen vannak az életünkben
a buliink na most ez a gyermekeinkért a
mozgalom nem az én kezdeményezésem azért
nem sorolnám fel hogy kik kezdeményezték
mert naag véletlenen valakit kifelejtsek
és akkor nem szeretném megbántani de
tény hogy és majd szép lassan színre
színre fog lépni a csapat még egy
előkészít és hlyik de ezt úgy képzeld el
hogy már a múlt év vége felé tehát már
novemberben voltam én azt hiszem az első
ilyen megbeszélésen tehát ezek
elsősorban szülők felelős szülők akik
azt látják hogy a saját tehát belátják
hogy a saját gyermekük jóléte múlik a
közösség jóétén nem most kezdték el
belátni mindig is ilyenek voltak úgy
képzeld el hogy régi diák
tevékenységemből ismerős emberek
régi-régi ismerősök ezek akikkel most
megint egy ügy kapcsán össze tudunk
fogni egyébként
nyitott a a pálya tehát sok emberre
lenne még szükség és majd akinek tetszik
az amit csinálunk csatlakozhat na most
kell egy szülő tudatosítás mert
elmondják a tanárok
hogy hogy mennyire tagadják a szülők
saját maguk ellen is a valót saját maguk
előtt é a valót tehát az én gyerekem nem
cigizik de értse meg hogy cigizett és
hogy megfogtam vagy a snüz tehát nem is
tudok én ezekről a tehát megint csak egy
burokban élünk az az igazság mert nem
tudunk egy csomó veszélyről ami am
ezeket a gyerekeket ami leselkedik
ezekre a gyerekekre mindenkiére a tiedre
is és az enyémre is nem kell még kise
kell menjen a házból ott van a képernyő
na most ezeket kezelni tudatosítani ha
összefogunk akkor csökkentjük ennek a
ennek az esélyét én először amikor ide
elhívtak engem akkor mivel olyan személy
hívott akit nagyra tartok és aki hiteles
az én szememben gondoltam hogy hogy ez
egy jó dolog lesz üüm és és elmentem de
voltak olyan szempontból fenntartásaim
hogy én ebben nem tudok seg
én nem látom ebben magam mertogy mindez
egy hiányból fakad üüm egy egy
kapcsolódási hiányból amit a gyermekek
megélnek és én ebben nem tudok segíteni
tehát én nem lehetek senkinek az
anyukája é az apukája nekem van kettő
tehát hogy hogy és én mit segítsek oda
tehát elsősorban a lelkeket kellene
ápolni és rendbe tenni és ez engem
meghalad ühüm és na de
elmentem nyilván azok akik ezt
kezdeményezték tudatában vannak ennek de
ezzel együtt akkor kell keresni azt a
helyzetet mert nem mindenki olyan
szerencsés hogy a szülei így figyeljenek
rá sokan kallódnak én látom azt hogy
micsoda sérülések érhetik ezeket a
gyerekeket miután látom hogy miken
küzdünk meg a bíróságon teljesen
fölösleges dolgok hogy rombol a
kapcsolaton tehát lehet válni szépen és
lehet cirkusszal az eredmény ugyanaz a
jogi értelemben mert elváltok viszont
hogy a kapcsolatokat egy életre
megmérgezi a gyermeket azzal bántod a
legjobban hogyha a szülőjét szíod neki
ezeket fel kéne mérni fel kéne fogni
tehát gyakorlatilag úgy megy a gyerek
bántalm hogy valami hihetetlen
gy nem nem de hát te gondolod hogy
otthon nem szidják egymásnak a két szülő
az egyik a másikat na tehát hogy és az
egy bántalmazás tehát fogjuk fel hogy ez
is egy bántalmazás én értem hogy a
legjobban te szereted nem is nem is
vonom kétségbe de szeresd jól szeresd
úgy hogy az a gyerek ne sérüljön tehát
egy csomó ilyen szakemberek vannak
pszichológusok tanárok így a csapatban
helyi rendőr van polgármesteri hivatali
alkalz ez ez hogy ezeket elő kell előre
kell
mozdítani fel kell hívni rá a figyelmet
és
igyekszünk igyekszünk megoldásokat
keresni vagy ajánlani vagy lehetőséget
adni képzések formájában
konfliktuskezelés
kommunikáció felhívni a szülőknek tehát
nem is tudjuk hogy mik vannak vannak
ilyen ilyen hogy snüsz például na most
láttam azt is hogy hogy néz ki ez a
snüsz ugye hogy csodálkozol én se tudtam
még ebben a csoportban nem kerültem ez a
snüsz azt hiszem hogy egy nikotinbomba
azt hiszem hogy ez a szó de hondjam
annyira az igazság az hogy nekem úgy úgy
be van úgy úgy dobozolva tudod hogy
rossz nem érdekel ki is találtam egy
szlogent ami majd az lesz hogy a snüsz
elég snassz aztán majd utána néznek
biztos sokan hogy mit mit is jelent az a
snassz igazából mert hogy valószínűleg a
gyerekek nem feltétlenül értik de hátha
utánanéznek és akkor már ami azt jelenti
hogy elég szegényes elég gáz üm
tehát ez a snüssz felteszik az ényökre
és nikotinnal látja el őket igen ám csak
nforvadást okoz egészségügyi problémákat
tehát nagyon-nagyon nagy veszélye van és
simán hozzájutnak a boltokban tehát hogy
egyrészt a boltoknak a felelősségét kell
kiemelni hogy nem adunk el 18 éven al
alatt se cigarettát sem alkoholos sem
energiaitalt semmit viszont nyilván
nagyon ehhez van azért hozzátenném az
összes többit a cukrozott üdítőitalakat
satöbbi satöbbi tehát hogy én tényleg
keveset tudok vásárolni a boltokban
hogyha azt nézem hogy hogy azok mennyire
károsak az egészségre na de nem eltérve
a témától én tudom azt hogy be tudom
küldeni a 18 évest és az majd vesz nekem
s 16 évesen kint megvárom tehát nem
biztos hogy ezek ellen tudunk tenni vagy
fel tudunk lépni viszont lehet hogyha
hogyha egy picit is legalább a az
embereket hogy hogy odaszólni vagy
beszólni vagy nem hagyni vagy
elbeszélgetni ott amikor ássz a
pénzszárnás látod hogy előtted
kiszolgálnak egy ilyen gyereket vagy
tehát hogy legalább szólni hogy figyelj
ez azért nincs rendben vagy vagy akár
akár az elárusítón nőknek aaszásoknak
legyen ez természetes hogy hogy nem
szolgálják őket ki mondom megvannak a
kiskapuk természetesen de azért ez is
már lehet hogy segítene
kampányokat tehát hogy mindenfélét
drogprevencióval a ki már bajban van nem
is látjuk ezeket hogy hogy mennyien
kerülnek igen is felhívni a figyelmet
arra hogy az udvarhelyi sürgösségi
osztályra hányan jutnak be
alkoholmérgezésbe fiatalok hm mi ezekről
nem tudunk mert hogy mondom burokban él
akeg ez egy kollektív monitorizálása az
aktuális helyzetnek tehát hogy szülőknek
és szakemberek akik folyamatosan
figyelnek hogy mi mi történik mert ezek
trendek valósz valószínűle egyéni
felelősséged ott vagy a boltban látsz
valamit tehát hogy igen ezzel együtt
társul ez s kor figyeliog mi történik é
együtt kollektívan lehet e igen akkor
lehet hogy elvennénk a kedvet akkor már
lehet hogy vagy egyáltalán hogy ez az
egyik a másik pedig az hogy mit mondtam
hiány van igaz valami hiányzik nézzük
meg mi az a hiány és mi mit tudunk
segíteni tudunk egy másik tevékenységet
ami érdekes lehet számodra kínálni
például az unatkozás a a mellőzöttség a
satöbbi
satöbbi kapj igen igen igen tehát hogy
hogy ezeket mondom szak én nem vagyok
ennek a szakemberre nekem megvan a magam
sávja hogy én hogy tudom őket segíteni
és milyen szakemberek vesznek részt ebbe
a mondom tehát pszichológusok tanárok
helyiendőr polgármester tehát be kell
vonni őket be kell vonni az iskolákat
hát nyilván az iskolák nélkül ezt nem
lehet és akkor az az iskoláknak is mi is
kell nyújtsunk valamit tehát őket is
kell segíteni ők is le vannak terhelve
még pont ez hiányzik de elvész a sok
bába között a gyermek hogyha erre is nem
figyelünk mert lesznek tehát
nagyon-nagyon sok információval lesznek
tele beteg lelkek olyan tapasztalatokkal
amik amik gyengítik őket a a jövőben
amelyek
majd később mentális betegségeket vagy
vagy akár csak depresszió tehát bármit
bármit elő tude idézni vagy szorongást
vagy tehát hogy hogy egy picit itt
próbálnánk segíteni ez nem fog menni
máról holnapra ez az egész például
szociológus is van a csoportban és akkor
ő készít elő készített már elő kérdőévet
amit az iskol ami folyik az iskolánkban
a a felmérés tehát hogy megnézni mindezt
megvizsgálni hogy mi hol tartunk
hihetetlen eredmények tudnak kijönni már
készített ilyen fel felmérést és csak
állunk és bámolunk és csodálkozunk
ezeket nyilván az iskolák megkapják
tudják hogy hogy mi van hogy hogy van
tehát fel kell mérni hogy hogy jutnak
hozzá nyilván sejtése vagy tudása erről
van a a szerveknek az erre szakosodott
szerveknek de hogy egy picit mi ezeket
megvizsgálva keressük meg azt ami a mai
tudásunk szerint a lehető legjobb
megoldás de mondom szakemberekkel na ez
az egyik az egyik ez egyik szívügyed az
egyik igen szívügy is de hogy hát
amennyire ugye az ember bele tud állni
de mondom én nekem nem ez a fele nekem
inkább megint csak a jog jö néha mondtam
is hogy szeretnék zsíros kenyeret
kenegetni mert hogy nekem is az lenne a
kikapcsolódás de hogyha nem kapnak mást
akkor akkor én ebben kell hogy segítsek
igen igen de van egyébként még két
jogász kolléganőtt ügyvédnőt megnyertem
a az ügynek majd még ők is seg digitális
biztonsággal kapcsolatban van
szakemberetek
nem tudnék erre a kérdésre igennel vagy
nemmel válaszolni mert nem ezzel
törődtem én de ha ajánkozol akkor biztos
hogy nincs elég szakember tehát hogy
elég szakember sosem tud lenni mert s eg
jobban foglalkoztat egyre jobban
foglalkoztat rá kellett jöjjek hogy
beszélgettünk így a generációkról amíg
készültünk és én az y generációhoz
tartozom aki egyáltalán nem érti már az
alfa generációt és meg kellett tanuljam
az é generációnak a gondolkodásmódját
hogy hogyan beszéljek az é generációhoz
úgyhogy rá kellett jöjjek
hogy nagy a szakadék köztem és az alfa
genereráció között hogy mit csinálnak és
az é generációnak a vége hogy milyen
rendek futnak folyamatosan én ezeket nem
követem a tiktok sincs felinstallálva a
a telefonomra
és és és nekem is tanulnom kell ebbe
tehát nem én vagyok a szakember aki
jelentkezem de ez mindenképpen a
fókuszom egyik középpontja lesz a
következő évben hogy szakembereket
keressek beszéltessem akár a navigátor
podcastbe is de de ezt a témát jobban
kibontani mert mindannyian mint szülők
tanulnunk kell ezt tanulnunk kell és
talán jogi szempontból én is meg foglak
kérni hogy majd legközelebb erről egyet
beszélgessünk hogy hogy mit is jelent a
digitális
biztonság szóval megtetszett ez a
mozgalom és remélem hogy amikor majd a a
felszínre jösztök és és el tehát
publikussá válik az a mozgalom igazából
már most is egy picit publikussá fog
válni ezáltal de amikor elkezditek a
tevékenységeteket sokkal látványosabban
akkor majd esetleg visszahívlak vagy
visszahívok valakit a mozgalom vezetői
közül egy kicsit beszélgessünk ezekről a
témákról mert mi szülők sokszor
segítségre szóulunk így van hát ebből ez
is az egyik kiindulópont
én tudom tehát nekem sem más ugyanúgy
amikor hazamegyek sőt én még le se vetem
a a munkát 8 óra munka után még ugye az
embernek mosogatás közben is dolgoznak a
a fejében a dolgok a a gondolatok de
ettől függetlenül mi el
elhatárolódhatunk hogy jaj mennyi dolgom
van jaj olyan fáradt vagyok egy kicsit
pihenjek meg persze ilyen napok is
kellenek de mindezzel együtt úgy
gondoljuk hogy nem engedhetjük meg
magunknak a teljes passzivitást ha
többen vagyunk oszlik a munka ha te
neked azt mondod hogy nagy a szakadék
közted és a további a későbbi generációk
között akkor ennek egyetlen egy módja a
hít az hogy kapcsolatot kell velük
teremteni el kell menni közéjük meg kell
ismerni őket nagyon-nagyon nyitottak
egyébként tehát én én amikor így megyek
persze van aki unja mert itt nem az
érdeklet nem is kell érdekeljen
mindenkit az amit én mondok de egy
fantasztikus nyitottság van egy nagy
őszinteség nagyon nagyon bájos akár
nyilván sokszor naivitással is társul
most nem egy bizonyos csoportról
beszélek hanem a tapasztalatom az ahány
osztályban voltam de nagyon jó volt
velük dolgozni nagyon vagány rálátásaik
vannak és megközelítéseik olyan ami ami
nekünk ezünkbe sem jut és azokból mi
mind-mind tanulunk tehát igen egy kicsit
lehet hogy bár nyilván tudom hogy te nem
így gondolkozol de azt kell elfelejteni
hogy mi amit ők nem tudnak és mi tudunk
az az ugye sokszor arra a téves
következtetésre jutunk hogy akkor ők nem
tudnak semmit de h nem tudnak már csak
arról nekünk fogalmunk sincsen azért
mert hogy nem is beszélgetünk egymással
és igen é be kell fogni a gyerekeink
tevékenységébe azért hogy megismerjük
ezáltal a saját gyerekeinket is te és
ahol van kötődés ott nincs hiány ott
nincs kortársorientáció ott nem kell
féljünk attól hogy mitől lesz függő a
gyermek üüm most ezt vetszőt tettem a
kettő közé tehát nem az egyik nem a
másiknak a függvénye csak mint problémát
inkább tehát felsor felsoroltam hogy
ezek bizony létező problémák amivel
szembbe kell nézzünk ühüm és ezt mi is
tanuljuk tehát nagy azt h hogy ez a
csoport ez ez mindent tud mi csak azt
látjuk hogy gond van vagy valami nem
működik és akkor nézzük meg azt hogy
hogy lehet működtetni na te mondtad az
áldozatiságot én mind ilyen emberekkel
vagyok körülvéve az az érzésem hogy
marha szerencsés vagyok én én engem
megtalálnak az ilyen emberek én
megtalálom őket nem tudom mindig volt
segítség körülöttem bármilyen nehézség
volt mindig mindig egy rakás jó emberre
találkoztam de tényleg és nekem ez egy
tanult dolog én meg kellett tanuljam
hogy szabad vagyok meg kell tanuljam
hogy felelősséget tudok és kell is
vállaljak a a dolgaimért az életemben
legalábbis jobban járok hogyha nem nem
próbálom másra kenni a
felelősséget de a környezetem amúgy
hasonló tehát ezt tanuljuk mindannyian
nekem is egy ilyen szempontból egy
burokba élek de de nem ez nem ez az
általános azt látom hogy hy az áldozat
mentalitás azért még mindig ott van
dominánsan a
környezetünkben tudod mi a felelősséged
akkor most már ezek utánát kell adni át
kell adni ha te ezt megtanultad át kell
adni lassan a beszélgetésünk végére
értünk igazából én ezt tovább tudnám
folytatni és eszembe is jutott egy
gondolat amit amit ha feldobnék akkor
még egy fél órát beszélgetnénk viszont
inkább azt kérdezném meg tőled hogy
van-e valami amiről még szeretnél
beszélni még körülbelül van öt
percünk vagy amennyit amennyi szükséges
hozzá de talán a zárógondolat az legyen
az amit amit amiről te szeretn beszélni
hm nyilván amikor az ember eljön egy
ilyen beszélgetésre akkor ugye
találgatja hogy mi lesz a téma meg hogy
lesz a téma meg hogy hova hova fogunk
haladni én az ilyen beszélgetések végén
sosem érzem azt hogy akkor hogy egy
gondolatot zártam- el le egyáltalán meg
hogy volt-e eleje és vége az egésznek
én én tudom azt hogy tehát ugye hozzám
az emberek a a szakmai életemben
elsősorban akkor jönnek ha problémájuk
van az is egy probléma hogy prevenció
tehát hogy hogy azért jövök hogy ne
legyen később problémám de de egy
helyzetet kell kezelni és nyilván a
nehézségeket látom tehát az a
nehézségoldal
mikor látom azt hogy szépen kialakulnak
elsimulnak a dolgok hogy sikerül
segíteni ez hatalmas sikerélmény tehát
mindenképp továbblendítés segít tehá nem
húz le mert mindig van valami ami méga
nehézség is van nehézséget is tapasztal
az ember vagy nem úgy alakulnak a dolgok
hiába teszek meg mindent mégis nem
sikerül akkor nyilván az megviseli az
embert de ezzel együtt én én nagyon
hiszem azt hogy
hogy az én életem az én kezemben van és
a környezetemet is én én tudom
hogy mi egymásra ugye hatással vagyunk
és tudjuk egymást erősíteni pontosan
pontosan és
hogyha minél többen csak úgy úgy
hát hát nem tudom most ebbe hogy azt
hiszem bele bele fogok bonyolóni
túlzottan de hogy hogy egyszerűsítsem
ragályos a proaktivitás ragályos a ha
látsz valakit igen utánzod tehát én
nagyon hiszek abban és nem csak azért
hiszek mert én szeretnék ebben hinni
hanem nekem meggyőződésem mert ez a
tapasztalatom nagyon röviden nagy
vonalúság nagyvonalúságot szül a
hülyeség hülyeséget és de tényleg és
lehet hogy nekem nem esik jól éppen de
ha én nagy vonalú tudok lenni vagy vagy
vagy komoly
konfliktusunk van de ha én nagyvonalú
vagyok és nem rogok bele a másikba
amikor ott van a lehetőség mert mit én
nem győzedelmeskerek nem kell ezt nekem
így kinyilvánítani akkor a másik ezt
nekem nem felejti el és miha y esélye
adódik rá ő is nagyvonalú lesz és
bizonyszorunk rá egymás nagyvonalúágára
időnként ezek kapcsok és így tudunk előr
menni tehát hogyha megállnánk azzal hogy
a sérelmeinket gyűjtögetjük és ezen
ücsörgünk nem mindig tudunk ezeken
változtatni el lehet fogadni ember neked
hogy jó te ilyen vagy te bántottál
van amit tudok benned szeretni ennek
ellenére és jó ha nem talsad a 2 m
távolságot én biztos fogom mert nekem
túl rövid az életem ahhoz hogy hogy
téged beengedjelek hogy rád időt és
energiát pazaroljak de a az összes
többivel tehát hogy hogy még így
is ha ha ki tudnánk lépni ezekből a a
sérelmekből mi magunk lennénk sokkal
boldogabbak
sokkal teljesebb életet tudunk élni
nekem tényleg mikor amikor építkezni
kellett azt mondták hogy úristen az
összes mesterember ilyen meg olyan hogy
hogy ne én pedig megmondtam nekik hogy
én ehhez semmit nem értek meg kérem úgy
csinálják hogy nekem az nagyon jó legyen
és nekem mindenki azon igyekezett hogy
nekem a legjobb legyen én elégedett is
vagyok én nem kellett szidjak senkit
látták hogy bízok bennük és ők mindent
megtettek hogy bizalomra mértóak
maradjanak pontosan pontosan nem abból
indultam ki hogy jaj ezek a
sztereotípiák hogy te biztos ki tudja
hogy mit fogtok it
eléemrk azut én beviszem én nekem még
csak szavaim sincsenek arra hogy
elmondjam hogy mi a bajon mondom hogy
aladin csodalámpája kigyúlt és akkor
gondolkoznaká tehát hogy nekem erre
vannak szavaim de ők aztán most már
tudnak engem kezelni értik amit mondani
próbálok vagy hogy hát ilyen hangokat ad
ki hogy meg mit t hangutánzó szavakkal
próbálok mert abszolút nem ért hozza de
megbízok bennük hogy biztos hogy a a
lehető legjobb munkát végzik egyszer úgy
jártam hogy ezt gyorsan elmondom a ültek
férfiemberek az autómban családtagokat
vittem le segesvára a vonathoz és
mondták az egyik mondta hogy elölkotyog
valami a másik hogy hátulkotyog valami
ugye az út is olyan segesvárig amilyen
és hogy feltétlenül vigyem el mert ezzel
az autóval nem lehet járni ez ez tönkre
van menve és mondtam nekik hogy fiuk hát
én én most voltam műszakizztatni ez tuti
fix hogy rendben van tehát olyan nincs
hogy e ez ne legyen rend de azért vidd
el jó hát elviszem hát ugye
felelősségteljes vagyok se az úthon nem
akarok maradni két gyereket sem akarok
magára hagyni csak azért mert mert
valami nem működik jól elviszem nagy
szégyenkezve elmondom
hogy hát az a helyzet hogy én tudom hogy
ők most műszakizzták le é minden rendben
van de a családtagok inszisztáltak hogy
tényleg azt mondják kotyog valami én
annyira nem is hallom de ha ők ezt
mondják nézzék meg a biztonság kedvéért
mikor megyek az autóért akkor kérdem
hogy na mi volt a gond és akkor nagy
röhögbe a azt mondták hogy kata rendet
tettünk a
csomagtartódban és én megköszöntem
tehát valami kotyogott igen valami
valóban kotyogos valószínűleg a
konfiguráció is változott hogy ugye ők
még a csomagjaikat betették a
családtagok na tehát hogy nem tudunk
mindenben a legjobbak lenni nem tudunk
mindig
mindent rendben magunk körül mindig van
valami el ami elmaradt mindig van egy
csomó elvégzendő dolog de hogyha mondjuk
ma két szerepemben három szerepemben jól
tudtam lenni mit én legyen ez a az anyai
szerepem a testvéri szerepem a baráti
szerepem akkor az egy jó nap mert ennél
többet teljesen fölösleges elvárnunk egy
naptól
igen hát így így sok sok mindenről
beszélgettünk de ami megmaradt bennem
nagyon élesen most így a beszélgetésünk
után az az hogy benned van
egy mélységes hit egyrészt abban hogy
szabad vagy és hogy szabad emberként te
vagy a felelős azokért adó és mindig
tehetsz valamit bármilyen kicsit is de
mindig tehetsz valamit így van ez az
egyik és a másik pedig az
hogy mindennek megvan a következménye
hogy ha jót teszel annak is megvan a
következménye ha rosszat teszel annak is
megvan a következménye ez az egyik
gondolat ami ami folyamatosan az elmúlt
években úgy úgy érlelgettem magamban
hogy soha senki semmit egyszer sem húsz
meg tehát hogyha valamit tesz annak
mindig meglesznek a következményei y és
lehet hogy ilyen szempontból csatolódunk
vissza mátyás királynak a a
történeteihez mert lehet hogy ezek a
gyermekmesék mégse gyermekmesék és lehet
hogy van valami nagyon fontos amit nem
szabad
elfelejtsünk ha egy módod van rá hogy
jót cselekedj tedd meg tedd meg és saját
magad tehát hogy magadat építed vele tök
mindegy hogy más tudja ezt vagy sem te
tudod ha rosszat teszel te tudod lehet
hogy más nem tudja de téged belülről mar
te soha nem fogsz tudni hitelesen
megállni és valamiről beszélni mert az
érződni fog a testbeszédeden a
beszédeden
mindenen tudod hogy ott valami van
amikor
te megmérettettél és nem voltál
elégséges megbuktál elég ha te tudod hát
miért kellene magunkat visszahúzzuk
ilyen gondolatokkal hát stó már
cselekedjünk úgy hogy ne legyenek később
ilyen gondolataink és akkor jól
alszunk köszönöm szépen kata a
beszélgetést én is köszönöm hát nem
tudom h mi sült ki de vagy remélem hogy
valami érthető is ezt majd a nézőink
eldöntik köszönöm szépen és majd akkor
várunk vissza a mozgalommal
kapcsolatbanö ja hát vagy vagy más vagy
meglátjuk hogy ki fog ki fog jönni
köszönöm szépen hogy legyen köszönöm
szépen szép napot mindenkinek sziasztok
ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz
fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna lit